Heute sind zwei Alltime-Favorites des Rasenfunks hier. Die Hebel-Brüder sind da, denn sie haben ein Buch über sich schreiben lassen, warum, wieso, weshalb und wie sich eigentlich der Kommentatoren-Job so verändert hat. Das besprechen wir jetzt im Rasenfunk. Und genau jetzt geht's los.
Das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch.
Achtung! Achtung! Nicht im Tor!
Kein Tor! Oder doch? Jetzt, was entscheidet der Linienöchter?
Tor!
Also es hat unser Professor schon immer gesagt, sie sind nur dann wichtig, wenn sie Protagonist werden. Also ich finde, das ist, also natürlich gibt es dann Situationen, wo du sagst, ich finde das und das nicht, aber es gibt im Grunde genommen, redest du eigentlich allgemein über die Protagonisten, das ist ja ganz normal. Aber wenn du natürlich dann einfach sagst, ich an meiner Stelle, ich bin jetzt hier Kommentator, ich muss jetzt hier sagen, für mich ist das keine rote Karte, weil aus dem und dem Grund, dann musst du es ja auch sagen. Du kannst ja nicht sagen, du kannst ja sagen laut Regelbuch, wenn jetzt der Konzept blank ist oder so. Aber natürlich ist es dann, wenn die Meinung von dir gefärbt werden muss, dann sagst du schon, ich finde den letzter Zeitplan. Und das mache ich auch, dass ich dann einfach mal z.B. sage, ich finde, das habe ich im letzten Spiel auch gesagt, ich finde, das ist sehr, sehr lustig, dass die deutschen Medien über Manchester United jetzt nicht mehr schreiben, wo es läuft. Größtes Kompliment an Michael Carrick überhaupt. Natürlich sagst du dann auch mal ich. Das ist ja ganz normal, das ist auch mit reingehört, ist ja logisch. Das ist auch ein Teil. Die Leute glauben immer, du bist, du musst neutral sein, wie sagt man, objektiv sein, du darfst irgendwie so neutral wie möglich sein. Das ist nicht der Fall. Du bist keine Zahlenmaschine, die einfach nur irgendwelche Wörter, Phrasen rausdrischt, sondern du bist ja dafür da, weil der Sender glaubt, du kannst es gut einschätzen. Vielleicht liegt der Sender falsch, dann habe ich Glück gehabt und sitze da trotzdem. Aber das ist ja der Punkt, es hat ja einen Grund, warum du da sitzt. Und es hat übrigens bei allen Kollegen einen Grund, dass die da sitzen und deshalb bei allen schiedsichtern einen Grund, dass die da stehen. Das ist so. Und das ist halt, glaube ich, was man auch immer manchmal vergisst. Du wirst dafür bezahlt, deine Meinung zu sagen. Und wenn die glauben, dass deine Meinung irgendwann mal komplett bescheuert ist, dann werden die dich wahrscheinlich auch ziemlich schneller wegholen.
Aber wirst du dafür bezahlt, deine Meinung zu sagen? Also mitunter ja. Oder wirst du dafür bezahlt, das bestehende Produkt in eine Geschichte zu verpacken und zu begleiten? Bist du nicht letztlich so eine Art Presenter des Spiels, das dir geboten wird?
Das ist ja immer ein Faktor, der auch mit dabei ist. Ich habe auch schon Spiele, das waren 0-0. Natürlich schrei ich hier nicht rum und sage, was ist das für eine Grütze? Weil der Zuschauer bezahlt dafür, das zu sehen. Der Zuschauer freut sich die ganze Woche auf dieses Spiel. Dann habe ich gefälligst auch, das ist mein Job. Aber ich darf natürlich sagen, heute ist es nichts. Oder es ist verhältnismäßig lahm oder so. Aber ich werde nicht persönlich beleidigt sein davon. Das meine ich damit. Und da schalte ich dann ab, wenn jemand persönlich beleidigt von etwas ist. Weil ich mir immer denke, ich freue mich auf dieses Spiel. Ich will, dass meine Mannschaft gewinnt. Ich will sehen, dass diese Spektakel von 1. gegen 2. Und wenn du dann persönlich beleidigt bist, das glaube ich ist nicht dein Job. Du hast recht, es ist immer eine Gratwanderung. Natürlich machst du dein eigenes Produkt auch nicht kaputt. Du wirst ja auch nicht sagen, jetzt bin ich hier im Rasenfunk, ich habe überhaupt keinen Bock auf das Tribünengespräch, weil der Gast ist echt eine Pfeife. Und überhaupt gibt es auch bessere Gespräche. Aber ich muss halt jetzt heute, natürlich sagst du auch, wir sind das beste... Du musst ja nicht wahren, wenn du sagst, du leitest den Zuschauern nicht dahin. Es gibt auch teilweise Situationen, da sagt dann mein Chef, oder meine Leiter der Sendung letztens sagt, warum feierst du das Spiel so? Es ist 0 zu 0. Ja, aber es passieren doch trotzdem Geschichten, die wert sind erzählt zu werden. Weil es keifen sich genau die beiden richtigen Spieler an. Es treffen genau die beiden richtigen Spieler aufeinander. Die beiden Trainer können eigentlich gar nicht miteinander. Das, was ich aufgeschrieben habe, dass passieren wird, passiert. Ich kann erklären, warum es passiert... Also es gibt so viele Dinge, die dich ja trotzdem erfreuen und die für den Zuschauer trotzdem erzählenswert sind. Dann vergisst der Zuschauer manchmal auch, hey, das ist ja eigentlich 0-0. Das gibt es auch und ich glaube, das ist schon auch deine Aufgabe. Aber du darfst natürlich auch nicht sagen, das ist das Spiel des Jahres. Das gibt es immer. Aber du bist ja trotzdem dafür da, diesen Zuschauer schmackhaft zu machen und dran zu bleiben. Das ist ja ganz normal. Aber das machst du ja normal. Es ist ja überall so. Keiner wird in einem Restaurant sagen, also vom Schnitzel würde ich jetzt heute die Finger lassen, weil das ist heute nicht gut. Das macht ja keiner.
Ein guter Kenner vielleicht schon, aber...
Aber dann kennt er dich. Sonst kommst du nie wieder, glaube ich.
Und wie ist das mit dem... Also jetzt haben wir das Ich besprochen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du da noch was ergänzen willst. Uli, du hast so ein bisschen...
Also ja, weil du gesagt hast, du bist der Presenter des Spiels. Wenn wir das machen, können wir aufhören, weil dann braucht es keinen Kommentar mehr. Der Kommentar in seiner Gattungsform, wie er mal war, ist, ich werde für meine Meinung bezahlt, für meinen Ausschnitt. Vielleicht ist das passender. Also ich sag dir ja, das ist das Schöne an dem Job, das ist das, was ich am meisten daran liebe, dass wir in der Redaktion über alles Mögliche diskutieren, im Vorfeld, im Nachhinein. Aber während der 90 Minuten sag ich, was ich denke, das richtig ist. Es klingt jetzt so, als würde ich mich so toll finden, dass ich nur das machen kann. Nein, sondern das Schöne ist einfach das, dann können wir Sport machen. Das ist das, wofür ich da bin. Also ich bin wirklich nur deswegen da.
Das ist wie Emma Eicher, wenn sie sagt, die besten Minuten sind die zwei Minuten unmittelbar vom Start, dann lassen sie alle mal in Ruhe.
Genau, ganz genau das ist es. Während des Spiels sind alle ruhig, essen, weil sie wissen, hoffentlich teuteuteute macht das schon. Oder die machen das schon ganz häufig inzwischen. Und das ist so schön, weil dann kannst du anfangen richtig reinzugehen, dich quasi Stück für Stück reinzuarbeiten. Das ist zum Beispiel, du hast Tom Bartels genannt, das liebe ich an ihm, der geht Stück für Stück für Stück für Stück rein in die Materie, ich liebe das. Und das macht mir den größten Spaß. Und wenn wir unseren Job so machen, wie er gemacht werden muss, dann ist genau diese Ursituation, die du vorher mal hattest, es sind die, die mit Rot gehen, es sind die, die mit Blau gehen. Und rate mal, die, die mit Rot gehen, wirst du nie erreichen, wenn du die Blauen hast. Das heißt, von den 50 Prozent, die du maximal erreichen kannst, wenn die Blauen nämlich 10-0 gewinnen gegen die Roten, wirst du aber auch 50 Prozent ganz sicher nicht haben. Und nur dann hat der Kommentar funktioniert, nur dann. Wenn du es von beiden Seiten abbekommst, dann hast du deinen Job richtig gemacht. Wenn nicht, begleitest du das Spiel und verkaufst es sozusagen, und da bin ich raus. Und wenn das passiert, höre ich auch auf mit dem Job.
Das heißt, weniger Beschreibung und mehr Meinung.
Ja, das musst du, finde ich, deswegen braucht es den Ich-Finde-Satz selten. Wenn du rhetorisch begabt genug bist, kannst du dir das sparen, weil dann ist sowieso klar, dass all das, was du hier sagst, deine Meinung ist.
Okay, also das ist das Ich. Wie viel du oder sie braucht es denn, das Durchbrechen der vierten Wand, die eigentlich ja gar keine vierte Wand ist? Also das ist jetzt ein schiefer Vergleich, dessen bin ich mir bewusst.
Es gibt manchmal Situationen, wie zum Beispiel, ich weiß noch damals, aber das ist ja dann auch so, dass du zum Beispiel, die Stellen jetzt, ich weiß noch, im ersten, dann kann ich es auch da ein Beispiel nennen, damit man es glaube ich auch dann vor Augen wirklich hat. Also nehme ich die Zuschauer schon wieder an die Hand, oder die Zuhörer.
Durchbrichst du gerade einfach ein bisschen.
Das erste Spiel, als Ruben Amorim umgestellt hat von Dreierkette auf Viererkette. Dann sagst du schon, schauen sie mal bitte jetzt hier die Viererkette an. Die haben mir Totale gezeigt, also das war nicht irgendwie eine Späterelektronik, das war nur der Anstoß. Und du sagst, schauen sie mal, es ist wirklich die Viererkette. Schauen sie mal rechts hinten diese. Dann machst du es natürlich schon. Aber du sagst jetzt sonst irgendwie, sie wissen ja oder so, wie sie wissen, das machst du eigentlich sonst normalerweise nicht. Aber wenn du es wirklich explizit dem Zuschauer ansprichst und ihm dann die Hand nimmst, dann kannst du schon, natürlich machst du es dann auch teilweise. Und da habe ich es dann eben explizit gemacht. Schauen sie mal bitte jetzt hinten rechts hin. McGuire, Shaw, keine Ahnung, wie die alle hießen. Die vier, ich weiß nicht mehr, wer das war. Das ist heute eine Viererkette. Genau so, wie wir es vermutet hatten und wie es die englischen Medien schon vermutet hatten. Der stellt heute um. Das ist ja unglaublich. Und dann macht es Sinn, weil du dann ja sagst, wenn ich nur gesagt hätte, Mensch, dass du heute heute mit einer Viererkette, dann hätte vielleicht gar keiner, also weniger anfangen können, vielleicht sich kurz orientieren müssen. Wo ist das denn? Wenn ich aber sage, schauen sie mal in den rechten Bildschirmrand, da stehen die. Oder es liegt noch einer unten oder sowas. Oder es flippt gerade einer rechts unten aus oder sowas. Dann macht es schon mal Sinn, den Zuschauern die Hand zu nehmen.
Wobei, dass ja eher so ein rhetorischer Trick der Aufmerksamkeit ist. Damit schießen die voll rein, dann schauen sie dahin. Aber was ich jetzt meine, ist quasi die Ansprache. Also sitzt für euch der Kommentator, so wie es auch physisch ja oft ist, im Stadion und ist eigentlich getrennt von den Zuschauern. Oder sitzt er mit den Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauern auf dem Sofa und nimmt sie mit. Weil interessanterweise ist es ja über Sorshmider so, dass es sich für die Menschen eher nach Letzterem anfühlt, was vorher nie eine Option war. Wir sind noch groß geworden mit Fußballkommentatorinnen, also eigentlich muss man da nicht gendern. Die waren in einer komplett anderen Welt. Heutzutage kann ich dir während des Spiels schreiben, ey, das war die 14. Gelbe Karte. Und du nimmst das vielleicht sogar noch in deinen Kommentaren. Ist doch interessant.
Ist es. Hat Vor- und Nachteile übrigens. Aber ja, ist es. Zum Begrüßen, das ist ganz klassisch, zum Begrüßen ist es häufig so, auch da versuche ich, hoffentlich gelingt es manchmal auch zu durchbrechen, nicht immer das Gleiche zu machen, zu markieren, mache ich das auch ganz häufig. Aber auch da muss ich immer zur Vorsicht mahnen, weil wenn du es halt zu oft machst, wird es auch nicht mehr funktionieren. Dann nervt das eher sogar und du schaust nicht mehr hin. Das heißt, dieses Stil mit dir musst du dir aufheben, wenn es wirklich wichtig wird.
Also quasi das schauen sie mal oder schaut mal.
Genau, wenn du nicht sozusagen anhalten kannst und mit der Zeitlupe den Pfeil einzeichnen kannst, sondern sie sehen den da jetzt rechts rumlaufen. Das ist jetzt wichtig für sie, weil ich sage ihnen gleich was dazu oder du oder wie auch immer. Und beim Teasing darf man nicht vergessen, das ist ein wichtiges Element geworden im Sportfernsehen.
Gibt es bald mal wieder einen Boxkampf, ja?
Ja, vielleicht kommt das bald wieder zurück ins Programm. Sieht gut aus, hoffe ich zumindest. Ansonsten versuche ich es ehrlich gesagt einfach aus rhetorischen Gründen zum umschiffen. Aber die semantische Frage, die dahinter steckt ist, sind wir über denen oder mit denen? Wir sind immer mit denen 100 Prozent. Aber ich glaube, wir dürfen während des Spiels nicht unbedingt zu viel wir zulassen, weil ich muss meinen Job machen. Dafür werde ich bezahlt. Und wenn ich anfange sozusagen eure Meinung zuzulassen, dann weicht sie auf. Und das ist nicht gut. Wenn du dann im Podcast so machen würdest, dass du nur nachliest, was so die grobe Meinung im Netz ist, dann wäre er nicht der, der er ist. Und im Grunde genommen ist das nicht so unterschiedlich, was wir hier tun.
Und wie viel Ahnung von Fußball sollte man als Kommentatorin oder Kommentar haben? Und wie wichtig ist diese Ahnung?
Die Regeln sollten wir alle drauf haben.
Na gut, da hört es bei manchen ehrlicherweise schon auf.
Es gibt immer eine Regel, auch da wieder to be fair, die hast du nicht. Und die letzte...
Das geht mir auch so. Aber wenn ich so... Ich habe es zum Beispiel... Neulich gab es den vermeintlich falschen Einwurf von Hoffenheim. Und das wurde in Spielzusammenfassung falsch zitiert. Da hieß es, man muss nur mit beiden Beinen hinter der Linie stehen oder auf der Linie, dann ist er korrekt ausgeführt. Und was aber... Man muss sich dahinter befinden, so war die Formulierung. Und das stimmt aber nicht, denn man muss stehen. Und der Spieler stand nicht. Und da denke ich mir dann... Also im Live-Kommentar, ey, mir fallen so oft Dinge nicht ein während des Podcasts, dass ich die Situation sehr gut kenne, dass man dann lieber nichts sagt als etwas Falsches zu sagen.
Aber ich sollte es natürlich schon... Also natürlich solltest du das wissen. Und vor allem, ich finde, mir macht es immer dann Spaß, wenn ich merke... Das hat zum Beispiel... Wenn du merkst, jemand hat Fußball gespielt und kennt so Nuancen, ich finde, mir macht es dann Spaß. Die Zahlen, außer wenn ich lerne und dann vortrage, das sind jetzt... Jetzt haben wir ja 17 Pässe in den ersten 10 Minuten.
Ja, aber das sollte die ja nicht Ahnung von Fußball haben. Ich meine quasi das Spiel verstehen. Weil gespielt haben wir es letztlich ja alle.
Ja, ja, aber das finde ich schon sehr wichtig. Es sind so Kleinigkeiten eben auch zu wissen, ist das, was die Mannschaft gerade macht, schwer, einfach, in welcher Psychologie befinden sich die und bei manchen Spielern genau dasselbe. Mir macht es immer dann Spaß, das meine ich eben damit, wenn ich verstehe, was diese Mannschaft gerade macht und warum sie es nicht macht oder warum sie es macht. Oder warum der Spieler das jetzt gerade nicht machen konnte, weil. Dann macht es Spaß. Natürlich musst du das verstehen. Natürlich musst du auch taktische Zusammenhänge verstehen. Wenn es zu viel wird, wird es zu viel. Auch das ist natürlich jetzt, dann wird es auch immer zu viel. Aber erklären zu können, warum eine Mannschaft das jetzt nicht kann und warum das und das jetzt aber gerade Sinn macht, warum sie es trotzdem tut, das macht auf jeden Fall Sinn. Natürlich war bei Liverpool letztens so. Da haben die Leute geschrieben, das ist so langweilig, die sind so schlecht und so weiter und so fort und die spielen ja nur unentschieden. Und ich habe mit Benni Grund halt davor erarbeitet, warum das jetzt der Fall ist. Weil sie einfach manche Dinge machen, um einfach nicht 0 zu 3 zu verlieren zum 5-Zenten-mal in Folge. Müssen sie es so und so machen. Und dann finde ich macht es Sinn. Natürlich hilft es, sich damit zu beschäftigen. Und ich persönlich mache es mir immer dann Spaß, wenn ich erkenne, warum ein Spieler jetzt gerade die Aktion macht und warum man das und das nicht kann. Mir ist zum Beispiel Helge Payer letztens geschrieben, dass er merkt, dass ich mich sehr mit Torbetten in letzter Zeit beschäftigt habe. Weil es mich einfach interessiert hat, warum macht der das und das und das. Ich war immer selber Stürmer bis in den Herrenbereich rein. Ich komme immer von der anderen Warte her und denke mir, wie hätte ich dem jetzt den Ball gegeben? Also was hätte ich gemacht? Und dann siehst du, weil ich genau weiss Torhüter machen eigentlich dann das. Also gebe ich ihm das, weil dann kann er das nicht. Und so und so. Und so macht mir es dann Spaß, wenn du verstehst, was der gerade mit dem Ball vorhat. Und ist es jetzt gerade schwierig, weil du halt selber mal einen Ball am Fuß hattest und sagst, okay, das ist jetzt echt schwierig, das ist jetzt echt gut, was der macht. Und das können jetzt nicht viele. Dann macht es mir Spaß, wenn ich dann zuschaue und zuhöre. Wenn ich verstehe, dass der versteht, okay, das ist jetzt hier special. Und sei es nur eine Annahme.
Genau, aber das ist ja das Ding. Dann sind wir ja so ein bisschen auf dem Matthias-Sommer-Pfad. Mit dem habe ich ja auch vor vielen Zeiten mein Tribünengespräch gemacht. Und der vertritt ja die alte Franz-Beckenbauer-These. Nur ehemalige Fußballprofis wissen eigentlich, wie Fußball läuft. Und nur die da sollten über Fußball reden. Da sind wir dann nicht in so einer Situation. Weil letztlich wissen wir ja alle nicht, wie es sich anfühlt, Fußball in der Bundesliga zu spielen.
In der Bundesliga, das ist natürlich ein fairer Punkt vor Zuschauern und vor Druck und so weiter. Da kannst du dich wirklich nur reinfühlen. Aber wenn du selber im Herrenbereich Fußball gespielt hast oder so was, dann weißt du ja ungefähr, ist jetzt schwierig, ist nicht so leicht, würde ich mir schwer tun. Das sind die Schwierigkeiten eines Spiels und so weiter und so fort. Wenn du das natürlich nur einmal gemacht hast am Bolzplatz, dann ist es natürlich eine andere Geschichte. Das ist schon klar. Aber ich finde nicht, dass jeder in der Bundesliga gespielt haben muss, um darüber zu reden. Weil ich kann ja das praktikabelste Gegenbeispiel nennen. Mario Basler.
Ja, ich habe jetzt eine kurze Pause gelassen, damit die Hörerinnen und Hörer den Satz vervollständigen können. Genau, ja, aber dann würde der ja immer richtig liegen. Aber was?
Dann würde Stefan Effenbeck ja immer richtig liegen.
Genau, genau, also das aber gleichzeitig ist es ja so. Also und ich verstehe das ja natürlich auch, dass das ihr müsst nicht die Taktik jetzt genau sezieren. Aber was ich schon interessant finde, ist ich bin natürlich eher der analytisch Schande und mir ist natürlich immer zu wenig Analyse. Das ist völlig klar. Ich weiß aber auch, ich bin nicht der Durchschnittszuschauer und die Durchschnittszuschauerin erst recht nicht. Aber was ich schon interessant finde, ist, dass ich manchmal Erkenntnisse zum Spiel während des Spiels gar nicht darstelle und erst danach dann wirksam werde. Also zum Beispiel eine Mannschaft dominiert die erste Hälfte, aus der zweiten Hälfte kommen sie raus und dann haben die ja logischerweise Anpassungen vorgenommen und oft sind die schwer zu erkennen. Auch für Leute wie uns, weil da geht es oft nur positionier dich 5 Meter weiter nach vorne. Wir machen es leicht anders im Anlaufen, so grob bleiben wir bei unserer Systematik. Es ist ultra schwer zu erkennen.
Es gibt 22 Spieler zu beobachten, nicht 5 und nicht einen. Im Duell, ich würde es dir manchmal, mir hat es dann Benni manchmal, schreibt mir mal unter dem Spiel, achte mal auf die Rechtsverteidiger gegen den Linksaußen, achte mal drauf. Der steht jetzt anders und dann sagst du, ok, stimmt, der hat recht. Dann siehst du das. Aber bei 22, wenn du alle, du hast ja immer die Übersicht. Da versuche ich mich mal ein bisschen eher anzunehmen, zu sagen, achte mal auf dieses Duell jetzt mehr. Da merke ich zum Beispiel, ich weiß ein Spiel noch von Uli und Helge, der Helge hat sich einfach immer nur auf ein Duell fokussiert. Uli hatte immer alle im Blick und er hat immer dieses eine Duell sie angeschaut. Das fand ich dann echt, dann hat es mir richtig Spaß gemacht, da auch hinzuschauen. Aber da braucht es manchmal schon auch einen zweiten, der dann einfach genau diesen Fokus drauflegen kann. Weil du musst halt oftmals alle 22 haben. Das ist manchmal schwer.
Ja genau, es ist schwierig und trotzdem sollte es ja aber eigentlich der Anspruch sein. Denn was mir wirklich häufig auffällt ist, man spürt so, es ist anders, es wird auch im Kommentar aufgefangen, ah, jetzt drücken sie mehr. Sie stehen ein bisschen höher, es ist inzwischen die Phrase für, sie haben irgendwas in der Pause umgestellt, ich kann euch nicht genau sagen was, deswegen sage ich, sie stehen höher. Sie laufen jetzt aggressiver an. Es ist auch so eine Schiffre für, ja, sie spielen halt jetzt mit. Und dann nach dem Spiel ist es dann aber so in den Pressekonferenzen oder in den On-Fade Interviews, dann sagen das ja manchmal die Trainer, was verändert wurde.
Und ab dann ist es Common Sense.
Exakt. Und ist das nicht, also ich weiß, dass das schwierig ist, weil ich erkenne es ja auch ganz oft nicht, aber eigentlich müsste es doch der Anspruch sein, dass man das irgendwie im On schon halbwegs hinbekommt, auch wenn man nicht Trainer sein kann in der Sekunde.
Ja, ich glaube aber gar nicht, dass es gewünscht ist. Also wir haben die Diskussion wahnsinnig häufig geführt.
Von wem nicht gewünscht? Von den Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauern?
Ne, das weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ob diejenigen, die über die Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer entscheiden, am Ende immer deren Wohl im Blick haben, sondern das ist aber auch super schwierig. Wie machst du das? Also machst du eine Umfrage?
Also vorhin ist die Sender quasi nicht, dass es eine Lügigkeit wird.
Wir haben letztens mit jemandem geredet, der gesagt hat, zum Beispiel, ich finde, die sind mir meine Kommentatoren, also ich werde jetzt nicht sagen, von wo, welcher Sender, es ist egal, also weit weg der Sender, sagen wir es mal so. Ich möchte nicht, dass die oftmals zu analytisch sind. Die gehen mir zu sehr darauf ein. Ich finde, die sollten mehr Emotionen rein.
Na gut, das sind ja immer alles Einzelmeinungen.
Es ist immer so, der eine hat der eine, der eine hat das, der andere das. Es ist auch Geschmackssache. Es gibt dann manche, die sagen, ich habe gerne, dass die rumschreien und es gibt manche, die sagen, ich will nicht, dass die rumschreien. Manche sagen, es ist mir zu viel. Bei der Zone am Anfang, weiß ich noch, da war ja fast alles Taktik. Sie sind sehr, sehr detailliert reingegangen. Das waren fünf Videos im Vorlauf. Und dann werden sie aufgenommen. Super Ansatz, neuer Ansatz damals. Und davon sind sie auch wieder ein bisschen weggegangen, weil sie gemerkt haben, es ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel. Es ist immer so eine Gradwanderung zwischen manchen gefällt es, manchen gefällt es nicht.
Ich versuche es mal so.
Ich verstehe, was du meinst, dass du das erkennen solltest. Ich fühle mich besser, wenn ich es erkenne. Sagen wir es so. Ich fühle mich besser, wenn ich es erkenne und dann auch nähnen kann. Und ärgere mich, wenn ich es nicht erkenne. Und dann sagt der Trainer danach, wir haben eigentlich das und das gemacht. Und ich denke mir, das hätte er eigentlich sehen können.
Und ich erkenne, dass Uli ganz dringend was sagen will.
Ja, nicht dringend. Ich versuche es mal so. Das ist ja immer nicht ganz leicht. Und das soll jetzt gar keine Senderkritik sein oder sonst irgendwas. Ich habe meine Idee, wie das Ganze zu laufen hat. Ich habe mir darüber jahrelange Gedanken gemacht und entwickle mein Produkt in Anführungszeichen ständig fort. Also ich habe ständig wechselt das, was ich tue, sozusagen. Weil ich manchmal denke, das ist gerade das, was es braucht. Das macht mir selber gerade Spaß und das nicht. Oder das meine ich trifft den Zeitgeist oder nicht. Oder da würde ich jetzt gerne versuchen, mal so etwas wie eine Marke zu setzen. Dass vielleicht auch andere sagen, ja, so müsste man das tun. Das ist immer anders. Also mein Kommentarverständnis von vor fünf Jahren ist nicht das von heute. Aber worauf man sich relativ schnell einigen kann, ist, dass die Sender am Ende die Masse begeistern müssen und damit sie Geld verdienen. Und die Masse holst du ab über Emotionen. Oder anders gesagt, man muss nur zwei Minuten ums Eck denken. Die würden alle nicht so viel Geld verdienen da, wenn es um Xs und Os gehen würde. Sondern sie verdienen Geld dadurch, dass sie sie emotionalisieren. Und emotionalisieren tust du nicht über Viererkette versus Fünferkette. Was ja per se schon Bullshit ist, weil es meistens gar keinen Unterschied macht. Also ich habe zum Beispiel schon vor Jahren gesagt, eigentlich ist die Startaufstellung, so wie wir sie vorher zeigen, komplett outdated.
Ja, das ist ja sowieso Quatsch. Es müsste zumindest Mit-
und Gegenball geben. Zumindest. Und das ist eh immer dynamisch. Also das siehst du ja schon, weil es ist eh Unsinn, was wir da machen.
Aber ist es nicht so, dass die, Entschuldigung, wenn ich dich unterbreche, aber ist es nicht so, dass die Emotionen doch sowieso da sind? Die kommen ja aus dem Spiel. Also niemand wird ja in der Sekunde, in der was Emotionales passiert, jetzt über das Verschieben des linken Achters reden. Aber wenn du dein Publikum letztlich auch ein bisschen klüger machst, indem du häufiger analytische Elemente zumindest mitbesprichst, kannst du ja sogar das Langweilige... Also es ist nicht so, dass jedes langweilige Spiel interessant wird durch die Taktikbrille. Das ist auch nicht die mehrere. Aber es wird ein bisschen interessanter.
Ja, das glaube ich auch. Das ist das, was ich mir aktuell aufbauen zum Beispiel meine. Also eigentlich könntest du ja viel mehr erzählen auf Überschreitungen.
Und das merke ich auch, dass mir Leute schreiben... Also wenn mir Leute schreiben, ich höre dich gerne, dann ist das auch natürlich weil Emotionen oder so. Weil man merkt, du hast Bock drauf. Aber es ist oft auch, ich habe heute wieder ein bisschen was gelernt. Also es gibt es wirklich, dass Leute mit mir schreiben, ich habe heute wieder ein bisschen was gelernt. Ich habe das Gefühl, du hast dich damit beschäftigt mit Sachen, die ich nicht weiß. Und dann macht es mir Spaß. Weil das sage ich auch immer wieder, es ist am Ende des Tages mein Job. Der Zuschauer arbeitet 40 Stunden die Woche, 60 Stunden die Woche, 80 Stunden die Woche, keine Ahnung, was er halt macht. Der kann sich nicht hinsetzen und sagen, was macht denn Liverpool anders als letzte Woche? Das wird selten einer tun. Er ist ein Nerd und hat da voll Bock. Aber die Masse macht es nicht. Das ist auch gut so. Dafür gibt es uns ja. Letzte Woche war übrigens das, das, das, das, das. Die haben taktisch so und so gespielt, heute wird es so und so. Ich glaube, es könnte so und so werden. Dafür telefonieren wir vorher mit Leuten. Ich mache es jedes Mal in der 2. Liga. Ich habe immer einen Reporter gesucht von vor Ort. Ich habe ihn nach wie vor noch, liebe Grüße an diejenigen, mit denen ich einfach telefoniere und dann verstehe, wo sind die gerade, was machen die gerade, wie sieht es taktisch aus. Dafür telefonierst du im Übrigen auch mit dem Trainer, dass du davor dann sagst, hey, pass auf, wie macht dir es heute. Das ist in der Bundesliga Gang und Gebe, dass die dir das auch sagen.
Aber das ist ja noch die Vorbereitung vorher. Ich finde das währenddessen so interessant, weil ich den Eindruck habe, dass man schon, ich glaube, das verändert sich nämlich auch schon so ein bisschen. Ich glaube, heutzutage durch verschiedene Effekte gibt es eine gewisse Anzahl an Fußballfans, die wissen schon viel, viel mehr als früher. Und die wissen auch viel mehr als wir drei hier. Das ist eh so. Es gibt immer den Nerter draußen, der viel, viel mehr weiß als du. Also man darf nicht glauben, man wüsste alles.
Die Bundesliga schaut auch die Bundesliga an, das darf man sich nie... Also die schauen alle zu. Wenn die Samstag spielen und Sonntag frei haben, schauen die zu. Die ganze Bundesliga. Und die wissen immer alles besser als wir. Das ist ja klar. Das ist ja die Natur der Sache. Das ist so.
Aber deswegen frage ich mich eben, warum das nicht einen größeren Fokus bekommt.
Also ich darf ja das so sagen, dass ich auch Teil dieser Bewegung sein wollte, weil ich das versucht habe zu etablieren und weiterhin versuche zu etablieren, in Maßen allerdings. Ist aber auch nur logisch. Wir haben vorher darüber gesprochen, dass Sender sich dann mitunter voneinander abzugrenzen haben, um einfach ein anderes Produkt zu sein. Ergo, wenn jetzt im Moment State of the Art ist, die drei, vier besten Kommentatoren in Deutschland, man kann es eh nicht messen, aber die, die im Moment die Top-Spiele bekommen, die gehen viel davon aus, die untersuchen Pressing, die untersuchen die verschiedenen Formen von Pressing, was weiß ich. Und ich möchte jetzt nur ins Game kommen, möchte mich beweisen, was mache ich? Ja, nicht den nach, sondern ich versuche entweder etwas anderes zu machen oder das, was der tut, zu nuancieren.
Ist das wirklich so? Weil ich habe den Eindruck, dass wir denselben Kometatoren-Typ reproduziert bekommen durch die nächste Generation.
Ja, das ist halt auch strategisch und ich bin sehr, sehr sicher, es ist halt nicht clever, weil du bist ja immer nur... Also wie willst du denn die Kopie verbessern? Das ist, also ja, das ist so und das ist normal, also möglicherweise auch im Fußball so, ne? Copycats, ganz viele. Der Marktführer wird kopiert und wenn die ganz gute Leute dabei sind, dann nehmen sie von den zwei Marktführer, wenn es die gibt, die zwei besten Elemente und mischen sie. Okay, aber wenn du jetzt einfach nur Wolfoost kopierst oder Fritz von Ton & Taxis versuchst zu kopieren, du wirst gnadenlos scheitern.
Aber den konnte man ja nicht kommentieren. Den konnte man nicht, Entschuldigung, duplizieren.
Deswegen war es gut.
Kopieren, genau, das ist eben das. Also wie du hast vorhin schon gesagt, Jogi, man muss seinen eigenen Stil finden. Und das ist ja auch eine Gratwanderung, weil du kommst rein ins Game in Anführungszeichen, in dem du gewisse Grundcharakteristika erfüllst, die quasi so in einem Mainstream entstammen. Und gleichzeitig muss man dann, man muss ein unheimliches Sprachgefühl haben und aber auch entwickeln. Ich glaube, man muss auch sein Vokabular, also da muss man durchaus darüber nachdenken, dass man mit Sprache arbeitet. Machen viele gar nicht, die bleiben dann quasi auf dem, wie sie angefangen haben. Aber in der idealen Welt, glaube ich, sollte man ein bisschen auch schärfen an Formulierungen, eben Flosken zum Beispiel vermeiden und so weiter und so fort. Und irgendwann dann, wenn man sich wohlfühlt, nachweist, wie viele X-Spielen, die man mal kommentiert hat, dann hat man ja überhaupt erstmal die Möglichkeit zu haben, das ist so mein Stil. Hier fühle ich mich wohl, das ist mein Vokabular.
Du bist ja dann auch erst frei, sag ich mal, weil du am Anfang ja immer noch so ein schonendes Gefühl hast, so quasi, boah, ist eine neue Situation für mich. Jetzt mittlerweile ist es, ich hab, da saß dann ein Praktikant neben mir, darf ich zuschauen? Also ich, oder dachte ich mal am Anfang so, boah, es wird irgendwie komisch werden. Da sitzt jetzt jemand, der schaut dir einfach zu, wenn es losgeht, geht es los. Und dann bist du wieder in deinem Ding. Da gibt es nichts. Aber da musst du hinkommen. Das stimmt wirklich. Da musst du hinkommen.
Und wie kannst du dann dein Stil entwickeln? Und ist es wirklich gewollt, dass Kommentierende einen eigenen Stil haben? Denn es gibt ganz, ganz wenige, die man voneinander wirklich unterscheiden könnte, außer an so Faktoren wie die Stimme oder den mag ich oder mag ich nicht.
Genau. Ja, spannende Frage. Generell aber, glaube ich, eine Frage unserer Welt. Auf der einen Seite möchte jeder gerne individuell sein, auf der anderen Seite ist aber das Individuelle immer das Gleiche. Oder vielleicht sogar dasselbe manchmal, weiß ich nicht. Ja, ich glaube aber, du kannst das nicht sein. Du kannst in dieser Branche nicht an die Spitze gehen, wenn du nicht eigene Elemente hast. Trotzdem muss es jetzt nicht, das muss ja nicht zirkusartig sein. Ich war, also die Frage, ob was gewollt ist. Ich bin mir gar nicht oft zu sicher, ob die Entscheider, ob die so hundertprozentig kalkuliert, analytisch rangehen an die ganze Sache. Da bin ich mir nicht zu sicher, weil auch die entscheiden häufig nach Sympathie und sei es nur nach der Sympathie der Zuschauer. Und wenn der eine halt gut ankommt, aus Grund XY kommt der andere, der ihn kopiert, ich sage jetzt, ob das so ist. Ich hoffe, wenn jemand das tut und an dem Punkt steht, dann was soll ich dazu noch sagen? Aber wenn das jemand tun würde, dann würde der natürlich entsprechend auch ganz gut wegkommen da. Ich bin der komplett festen Überzeugung, dass du das nur schaffen kannst, wenn du dich irgendwann einmal, nach einer Zeit, am Anfang spielst du das. Das sind diese hundert Spiele, die man immer so als ob es 100 oder 150 sind, das ist auch Typfrage sicher. Am Anfang spielst du ganz viel von dem, was du irgendwann früher mal gehört hast und schaust dir eine Kollegin xy an, nimmst dir das von dem weg, nimmst dir das von dem weg, nimmst dir das von dem weg. Im Zweifel hast du eine Schulung bekommen, Handwerk und so, und lässt die verschiedenen Dinge mit einfließen und irgendwann sagst du, okay, was mir aber fehlt ist, oder was ich gerne gehabt hätte, wäre. Und dann baust du das auch noch mit ein und dann hast du zumindest so etwas, wie in deinem eigenen Stil. Dann gibt es natürlich diese, wo du halt auch die Haltung manchmal merkst bei Kollegen, einige sind eher zynischer, manche arbeiten viel mit Ironie. Das ist dann hoffentlich der Typ, den du irgendwann spürst. Und manche sind erstmal grundpositiv dem Spiel gegenüber, zunächst einmal, manche gehen aber schon rein und sagen, um Himmels willen, Bundesliga. Was ich manchmal auch verstehen kann. Aber trotzdem sollten wir professionell genug sein. Aber die Frage darf wahrscheinlich gar nicht an uns selber gehen, weil wir sind ja ich AGs unterm Strich. Sondern die müsste wahrscheinlich an die Entscheider gehen, inwiefern sie denn versuchen, überhaupt unterschiedliche Typen zu haben.
Da habe ich nicht das Gefühl, dass auf Vokabular und...
Nein, das habe ich auch nicht...
.geachtet wird. Glaubt ihr, dass sich das verändert hat, wie kommentiert wird, dadurch, dass die aktuelle Generation, die kommentiert, und dazu zähle ich euch auch, durch Fußballsimulationen mit Haupt geprägt wurde. Wir alle haben FIFA, Pro Evolution Soccer, was auch immer gezockt. Und es ist ja ganz interessant, dass diese Versatzstücke, die da verwendet werden, auch die immer gleichen Witze, ihr könntet wahrscheinlich auf Kommando jetzt immer noch da manche Dinge vorbringen. Glaubt ihr, dass das auch die Art und Weise verändert hat, wie quasi diese Generation Fußballspiele kommentiert, weil wir es eigentlich irgendwie immer so ein bisschen im Hinterkopf haben?
Also am Anfang mit Sicherheit, ja. Am Anfang mit Sicherheit, wie gesagt, nochmal, wenn mir jemand ein Beispiel schickt, das ist halt Zusammenfassung oftmals nur, dann sind diese Fragmente immer drin. Es sind immer die gleichen Fragmente. Und auch zum Beispiel, das ist auch immer ein Trick, den ich anwende, der sehr witzig ist, wenn du einfach mal sagst, hör dir mal die Zusammenfassung an oder hör dir mal ein Spiel an. Und das ist jetzt dann wirklich Life Hack. Und sag mal, und zähl mal, wie oft vorkommt, was für ein? Was für ein Schuss, was für ein Tor, was für ein Foul, was für ein Spiel, was für eine Szene.
Oder die verbesserte Warn-Di-Was-Ein?
Was ein, genau. Wenn du das hörst, dann weißt du schon, also dann weißt du schon, dass das hat einfach, wie du sagst, das hat sich eingeschlüpfen, wer hat damit angefangen? Es ist wahrscheinlich das englische Water, Water Goal oder sowas. Und dann haben die das irgendwie übersetzt, hat irgendjemand übersetzt und fängt damit an. Aber ich mach das zum Beispiel, also wenn mir das rausrutscht, ärgere ich mich immer, weil entweder ich bin dann wirklich überrascht, was jetzt hier passiert oder ich denke mir einfach, ich glaube, es mir einmal passiert, dass ich mir echt dachte, wieso sagst du das jetzt auch? Aber da war ich wirklich überrascht von der Situation. Aber normalerweise sage ich es nicht, weil meine Aufgabe ist ja zu sagen, was ist das für ein Tor?
Exakt, eigentlich musst du, ja.
Genau, und das ist eigentlich meine Aufgabe. Und da siehst du, dass Leute sich, dass wenn dieser Satz kommt, und ich lach dann immer wieder drüber, nicht, weil wenn du es einmal hörst, dann kannst du es nicht immer nicht hören. Aber wenn du das nicht hörst, wahrscheinlich werden alle Zuschauer jetzt und Zuhörer wahrscheinlich jetzt versaut sein und sich denken, jetzt hat er es auch gesagt, es kommt in jedem Spiel halt einfach vor. Und ich glaube, das hat sich einfach eingeschlüfft. Irgendjemand hat mal angefangen, der ist dann mit Viral gegangen wahrscheinlich, wie du sagst, der ging wahrscheinlich um die Wette, dann dachten alle, es ist irgendwie cool, es klingt irgendwie cool, dann macht es der nächste auch. Und irgendwann dachten alle, es ist ja irgendwie cool, es gehört schon irgendwie dazu. Aber ich finde eben, wir sollten eher davon weggehen und sagen, nee, es ist nicht was für ein Tor, sondern das ist hier ein herausragendes Tor, oder das ist das Tor des Jahrtausends, oder was weiß ich, oder ein absolutes...
Ein halbes, super lauthieberes Tor.
Es ist ein Gurgentor, oder was weiß ich, oder es ist jetzt hier zufällig, was weiß ich, egal was, es ist einfach zu beschreiben, besser als... Oder einzuordnen, sagen wir es so, besser als zu sagen, was für ein.
Das ist ja das, was mich wahnsinnig nervt, aber das generiell nervt mich am Journalismus, nervt mich auch an miesen Büchern, oder miesen Filmen. Also wenn du im Stadion bist, dann kannst du verschiedene Filter anwenden und du kannst sagen, die Stimmung ist grandios. Das macht nichts in mir. Wenn du mir beschreibst, warum sie grandios ist, was ist denn so grandios? Was ist besonders? Was passiert um dich rum?
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie es hören können, aber hier fliegt das Dach weg.
Genau, genau. Ja, genau.
Wobei das sind ja dann schon wieder diese Markerworte, die man ja eigentlich versucht zu umschiffen. Also oder muss man es versuchen?
Ich glaube, du umschiffst sie dann, wenn du dir einmal klargemacht hast, dass du ein Sprachprofi sein solltest und dass das deine Währung ist. Dann umschiffst du sie, wenn du es einmal verstehst. Und das ist das, was ich meine. Du bist es nicht, du bist kein Kommentator, Moderator, wie auch immer, solange du das alles zusammenkopierst von den anderen. Du bist es erst dann, wenn das Ganze deine eigene Färbung bekommt. Ich habe einen Kollegen im Radio gehabt, der mir gesagt hat, ich will nicht mehr. Das ist zu viel. Er fasst sich ein Herz und das ganze Zeug. Und dann hat er gemeint, ja, aber das hört man ja gerne. Und ich habe gesagt, wer denn? Wer hört das denn gerne? Also was sind denn die Momente, die in Anführungszeichen viral gehen? Das sind doch die Besonderen. Warum ist Wolfoost da, wo er ist? Weil er das besser kann als andere, dass er Bilder erschafft.
Weil er damals einfach komplett anders war.
Manchmal verhebt er sich auch damit.
Zehn tragen das Klavier einer Spielt, Stephen Jarrah.
Genau, manchmal verhebt er sich auch. Aber das, was dann hängen bleibt, die Momente sind die, wo ich sage, da hat jemand was selbst kreiert.
Und damit touchst du dich ja auch. Wenn ich jetzt zum 13. Mal sage, was für einen, dann ist es ja einfach nur den gleichen Aufkleber wieder drauf, dieselbe Briefmarke wieder drauf.
Der Kollege hat mir felsenfest versichert, dass er sich darüber im Klaren ist, dass die Radio-Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer nichts anderes hören wollen, als das, was sie schon immer hören. Immerhin, immerhin hat er sich dazu verhalten und hat sich Gedanken darüber gemacht. Dann, okay, Floskel weiter, wenn du magst, ich bin raus, aber Floskel, wie du willst, okay. Ich bezweifle es einfach nur. Ich möchte nicht hören, wenn, was weiß ich, in in Leverkusen die Meisterschaft passiert. Dann ist das, dann ist das monumental. Vielleicht wird es auch nie wieder passieren. Und ist mir schon klar, dass die Stimmung grandios ist. Oder was weiß ich, wenn, sollte, sollten die Wolverine Wanderers noch den Klassenerhalt schaffen. Sie haben auch drei Punkte Fenster hier offen. Wenn sie den schaffen, dann möchte ich nicht hören, dass das Dach hier wegfliegt oder die Stimmung grandios ist. Ist mir schon klar. Aber ist es Rührung, ist es Erleichterung? Was nimmst du wahr? Deswegen bist du da. Das ist im Übrigen unser Hauptargument pro Stadion, ne. Deswegen sind wir da. Wenn du dann einfach nur reproduzierst, was du die letzten 16 Spiele aus der Box auch reproduziert hast, haben wir weniger Argumente. Du kannst mit dem Trainer sprechen. Okay, wow. Aber das nervt mich. Da bin ich raus. Und ich weiß auch, dass manche, die das vielleicht auch hier hören, weiß ich nicht, aber Kolleginnen und Kollegen nervt, dass ich das fast religiös mache. Wir müssen vernünftige Sprache haben. Weil du hast es vorher gesagt, uns hören manchmal noch Leute zu, die anderen nicht mehr zuhören. Das hat einmal den sprachlichen Aspekt, der ist geschenkt, aber das hat manchmal auch den humanen Aspekt, dass wir Clip und klar Rassismus verurteilen, Ausgrenzung jeglicher Form verurteilen, weil sie uns hören, aber sonst nichts mehr einschalten oder lesen. Und dann muss ich sie halt manchmal überfordern. Das mache ich dann auch gerne. Das strengt die vielleicht auch an, macht mir auch manchmal unsympathisch. Okay, damit lebe ich. Das ist mein Stil, in Anführungszeichen.
Und wie arbeitet ihr mit eurer Sprache? Denn wir alle verfügen über ein Vokabular und ganz viel wird das geprägt über früher, über Dinge, die man gelesen hat heutzutage. Es ist viel geprägt über Dinge, die man gesehen hat. Und gleichzeitig ist es aber auch so, dass man an seine persönliche Grenze stößt. Also es ist ja auch gut erforscht, dass quasi jeder Mensch so seine tausende Wörter an Vokabular hat und aus dem bewegt man sich selten raus. Und wenn man das durchbrechen möchte, das ist mir zum Beispiel so gegangen. Ich habe, wenn ich Roger Williamson gelesen habe, da weiß ich, da sind wir uns ähnlich, da könnte ich heulen vor Frust, wie gut dieser Mensch formulieren kann. Kein Satz Anfang desgleich im kompletten Buch. Und doch zieht es mich quasi an der Hand durch die Seiten hindurch. Und das würde ich nie im Leben hinbekommen. Und trotzdem ist es aber so, dass ein so etwas prägt. Also wenn du eben gewisse Autorinnen und Autoren liest, dann, also manchmal ist es auch richtig so, das hatte ich früher vor allem im Studium. Ich habe auch Germanistik studiert, muss ich dazu sagen. Aber wenn ich dann quasi von einem Autor einfach mal so fünf Bücher gelesen habe, dann habe ich manchmal richtig in Sätzen von demjenigen gedacht. Das war total verrückt. Also wie arbeitet ihr an eurer Sprache? Und habt ihr den Eindruck, dass das auch wirklich eine Rolle spielt, auch jenseits von dem, was ihr jetzt macht in eurem Job?
Also ich kann es nur für mich sagen, das ist wahrscheinlich wahnsinnig individuell. Lesen zum einen, hören zum anderen. Also ich höre es sehr gerne auch, sei es jetzt Bücher, Podcasts oder generell Dinge. Und es ist glaube ich auch durchaus sinnvoll, alles Mögliche zu lesen. Also selbst in der Apotheken Umschau gibt es manchmal so Stilleblüten in Anführungszeichen, wo man sich, also, na? Und ich habe ein Büchlein, wo quasi, also ich mache das auch mit meinen Studenten in der Uni immer. Da unterrichte ich auch Live-Berichterstattung. Den gehe ich auch immer genauso auf den Zeiger mit all diesen sprachlichen A-Ungenauigkeiten und vor allen Dingen Kopierereien. Da mache ich immer die burgunderfarbene Liste, weil die rote Liste ja auch schon eine Floskel für sich wäre. Und so habe ich meine Floskel etabliert und dann kommen all diese Formulierungen auf den Index. Und sobald die bei mir einmal auf dem Herzensindex sind oder aber im Buchindex stehen, sind die für mich gestrichen und dann kommen sie nicht mehr. Und dann kann ich mich auf mich verlassen. Und das ist mal das Wichtigste, dass ich die alle mal beseitige. Die benutzten Formulierungen, die beseitige ich alle mal. Das ist das Schöne und das Gute. Und dann geht es ja aber auch irgendwann daran, sich eher positiv sozusagen weiterzubilden. Und ich habe, das ist eine Idealforbereitung von mir. Sieht so aus, wenn ich die Zeit noch habe. Das klappt mal besser, mal schlechter. Aber wenn ich ideal vorbereitet bin und ich habe wirklich noch zwei, drei Stunden zwischen, was weiß ich, Anreise oder Vorbereitung. Ich leg den Stift weg, weil ich das jetzt zum sechsthundertsten Mal lese, was passiert. Dann versuche ich tatsächlich noch einmal, ich habe eine Library auf dem Telefon, dann versuche ich noch einmal Roger Wilhelmsen zu hören, um mich einfach nur in den Gedankengang zu konfigurieren. Ich muss zumindest versuchen, in die Nähe zu kommen, dessen, was ich da höre. Wäre ich nicht schaffen, aber zumindest in die Nähe muss ich kommen. Dann motiviere ich mich sozusagen selber, vernünftig zu sprechen, keine Lautverzögerungen und so weiter. Das ist auf Sendung eh Wahnsinn, das darf nie passieren, aber zumindest versuche ich das so gut ich kann, dann so anzugehen und das ist der Part, auf dem ich mich fortbewege. Versuche möglichst viele verschiedene Einflüsse zu haben und berührt zu werden davon, damit es bleibt. Weil das ist glaube ich das, was am Ende bleibt, was dich wirklich fängt. Also dieser Autor, Ruga Williamson, hat mich auf ganz verschiedenen Ebenen gefangen in meinem Leben. Also am Anfang habe ich den gehört und mir gedacht, der ist gut, aber ich habe ihn mir nicht behalten. Noch einmal gehört, ich dachte, Mensch, der ist irgendwie gut. Dann war es in die Finger bekommen, gedacht, Mensch, das ist wirklich gut. Und so ist er bei mir quasi.
Aber kann man das noch weiterentwickeln? Also irgendwann geht die Unsicherheit weg. Gleichzeitig ist es ja aber auch so, es muss immer zu dir passen. Also man mag dir auch total, wenn Kommentatoren oder Kommentatorinnen eine Rolle spielen. Oder ja, genau, das gibt es auch durchaus bei bekannten Beispielen. Glaube ich, dass manchmal zu hören, dass manchmal der Gag schon vor Spiel beginnt.
Aber auch da, um fair zu sein, es gibt ja manchmal Gedanken, die kommen dir in der Nacht. Ich bin auch schon im Bett gelegen und dachte mir, das ist ein genialer Gedanke, das ist eine geniale Formulierung. Oder die beiden Sachen zusammenzubringen, ist überragend. Dann hast du die in deinem Kopf ja auch schon vorgeschrieben. Das gibt es ja manchmal auch.
Das ist auch okay.
Das ist Vorbereitung. Manchmal ist es so, dass du einfach denkst, das ist genial, diese beiden Punkte zusammenzubringen und das mit der und der Weltlage zu vergleichen. Das ist ein Kernamtum als Beispiel, weil wir denken jetzt an etwas Negatives. Aber es gibt ja manchmal Situationen, es gibt virale, zum Beispiel war einmal die Situation mit dem, wie ist der gerne mal der Knöllchenmeister, wie ist der?
Der Anzeigenhauptmeister.
Wenn eine lustige Schiedsrichter-Situation kommt, da alles mit dem Anzeigenhauptmeister irgendwie. Das glaube ich könnte genial sein, einfach mal diese Idee. Und dann kam zwei Wochen später genau die Situation und hat es gepasst. Und dann ging es viral. Aber natürlich reinquetschen bringt nichts. Aber es gibt mal Situationen, da passt es einfach.
Und das ist aber die Währung, ob es viral geht oder?
Nein, aber du weißt ja, das funktioniert. Sagen wir so, die Zuschauer nehmen es an. Und dann passt es manchmal. Ich habe zum Beispiel, ich fand da immer, der hat es mal ein bisschen übertrieben, aber Johannes B. Kerner zum Beispiel, ich finde, der hatte immer einen sehr, sehr guten, der hatte, das habe ich genial gefunden teilweise, wie der so Phänomene, die momentan auf der Welt passieren, immer irgendwie eingeflochten hat, dass man sich dachte, ich verstehe, was er meint. Und das hat mich damals immer gecatcht, weil ich dachte, das ist genial. Er ist einfach so, er nimmt diese aktuelle Lage, das Ding, über das gerade jeder redet und baut es aber irgendwie so ein, dass es nicht billig klingt. Und das ist ja schon irgendwie, der Gedanke hat mir gefallen. Und dann arbeitest du mit solchen Dingen halt zum Beispiel. Manchmal gibt es auch ganz plump eine Formulierung, wo du sagst, ein Wort, wo du denkst, das ist ein schönes Wort, habe ich in Ewigkeit nicht mehr gehört, schreibe ich mir das auf, einfach nur um es zu manifestieren im Kopf.
Das hat Jigves Eigenrauch immer gemacht.
Das gibt es manchmal auch.
Weiß ich noch ganz genau. Der Nominator für die Nationalelf wurde ihm eine Frage auf der Pressekonferenz gestellt. Und dann meinte er, das ist ja ein tolles Wort. Das schreibe ich direkt in meinem Büchlein. Und dann hat er ein kleines schwarzes Buch rausgeholt.
Gibt es manchmal auch. Es gibt auch manchmal gewisse Personen. Bei mir ist es ein bisschen plumper als bei Uli. Ich liebe zum Beispiel, wie Harald Schmidt von A nach B kommt. Ich schaue mir alte Harald Schmidt-Vorfolgen an. Ich schaue mir 13 Mal an. Weil ich liebe, wie der von A nach B kommt, wie der ohne Probleme einfach noch so einen so einen Nebensatz einbaust, wo du dir denkst, da steckt die Welt drin. Und das ist aber so nebenbei und das ist nur mit einem Schnauben schon wieder. Und das ist bei mir so. Ich schaue mir das an und denke mir einfach nur, wie genial geht der mit Sprache um, wie geht der mit dem Publikum um, wie geht der mit seinem Material um, das er hat und kommt von A nach B. Ich liebe das einfach, weil das einfach ein Genie ist, was das betrifft. Und dann denkst du dir manchmal so, das ist überragend, wie der das macht. Aber am Ende ist es gar keine. Du schreibst einfach eine Wörter auf, du schreibst Formulierungen auf, du liest viel, du hörst viel. Es ist eine Mischung aus allem, wo du dir sagst, so versuche ich irgendwie, damit umzugehen.
Am Ende ist es auch innere Feedback-Kultur. Jeder von uns hat Füllwörter, die er benutzt. Du musst sozusagen dein Geist, also glaube ich, wenn du in diesem, also ich verdiene mein Geld mitsprechen. Und wenn ich das weiterhin auf hohem Niveau machen möchte und noch meinen eigenen Ansprüchen und auch hoffentlich den hohen Desenders gerecht werden will, dann muss ich Wege finden, dass ich härter bin zu mir als andere, damit ich es vor denen merke. Und in dem Moment, wo mir das, ich habe zum Beispiel, das darf ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber ich habe gerade die Tendenz, ich habe in meinem Spiel am Sonntag drei Mal gesagt, schlicht. Und beim zweiten Mal ist es mir aufgefallen, ich habe gedacht, mann, und dann habe ich es nochmal gesagt und dann musste ich es mir aufschrauben, jetzt ist es raus. Das wird jetzt nicht mehr kommen. Aber weil ich es meistens entweder bei Gegenübern, ein gutes Wort, schreibe ich auch, schnell feststelle, ja genau, aber nicht im Bügel, also am Telefon.
Das ist aber nur zweimal verwendet.
Das ist nur halb so cool. Und dann, das muss mir auffallen, ich muss aber auch kritisch zu mir selbst sein. Die Fehlsenderei tut auch seines dazu, dass man logischerweise hier und da schludrig wird.
Man ist ja auch manchmal einfach müde, oder?
Es gibt mal Spiele, wo du am Wochenende am Donnerstag Europa League kommst um 0 Uhr raus, weil ich vorhin Schießen gehabt hatte. Freitag ist die zweite Liga. Normalerweise mache ich in der zweiten Liga immer zwei Vorbereitungstage. Da muss ich alles in einen Tag reindrücken. Und dann hast du am nächsten Tag Premier League sofort am Mittag und hast am nächsten Tag am Mittag sofort wieder nochmal ein Premier League Spiel. Oder zweite Liga nochmal. Dass du dann natürlich auch hangelst und natürlich nicht so befreit sein kannst, als Spieltag 1 nach August.
Ganz anders noch, also viel nachvollziehbarer wahrscheinlich. Wir alle haben Privatleben. Und es gibt halt mal bessere, mal schlechtere Tage. Du bist mal von etwas genervt, mal nicht.
Es gab einen Tag, ein Spiel, da haben sie mir das Auto zerkratzt. Und ich hab das auf dem Parkplatz bei Sky gemerkt, als ich ausgestiegen bin. Habe es davor nicht gemerkt, weil es andere Seite war. Und dann gehst du in ein Spiel rein und natürlich bist du da nicht, ja liebe Zuschauer, es ist ja der Wahnsinn, sondern da bist du halt gefühlt, gefühlt willst du am liebsten mit dem Schlagstock rumlaufen und alle verdreschen. Das gibt es auch. Auch das weiß der Zuschauer ja nicht. Da musst du dann auch professionell sein und sagen, okay, das ist jetzt egal, in 90 Minuten geht es nicht.
Wir können es ganz leicht lösen, indem wir die Tagesätze wieder erhöhen, so wie in früheren Zeiten, dann muss man weniger machen.
Dann muss man sich über sowas nicht mehr ärgern.
Ich glaube, das ist gar nicht oft, sondern es ist ja schön und es macht ja Spaß und wir schauen es ja eh so oder so, von daher kann man auch schon seinen Senf dazu geben.
Die vierte Mauer nochmal durchbrechen. Drückst du jedes Mal, wenn ich reusspaar eigentlich?
Ich markiere mir hier, wann ich dich rausblute.
Das ist unglaublich, da hast du viel zu tun. Ich reusspaar nämlich sehr viel.
Das weiß ich, aber das ist ja auch gar kein Problem.
Es hat mich interessiert, da haben wir Zuschauer mitgenommen.
Manchmal mache ich hier aber auch Kapitelmarken usw. Ich mache relativ viel in dem Herbe.
Ich merke es schon, aber es ist gut, ich werde es aber nur interessiert. Und da ist mir aufgefallen, dass du immer drückst, wenn ich reusspaar, ist es mir aufgefallen, das ist ja das, was die Hörerinnen und Hörer auch nicht sehen.
Also das, was ich hier mache, ist quasi das kleinste Setup, weil ich will ja mit euch reden. Wenn wir jetzt hier in unserem Call werden, wie bei der Liga Tour, da mache ich tausend Sachen nebenher, da wird die Kapitelmarke schon mal benannt, die wird an die richtige Stelle geschoben, dann markiere ich mir, dass ich hier noch was vergessen habe, rechts mache ich schon den Tap von La Liga auf, weil ich noch gerade über Premier League rede. Und da passiert es nämlich dann auch manchmal, dass man dann so den Moment für das Einsteigen verpasst oder den Namen nicht richtig gehört hat des Spielers, der erwähnt wurde. Und da denken sich die Leute draußen, warum hat er da nicht XY? Und da war es auch meine Schuld, weil ich zu viele E-Mails gemacht habe.
Hatte ich heute im Podcast übrigens, als du über Newcastle geredet hast.
Ich war es. Ich mache das genauso. Ich habe mir, glaube ich, nur auch da ganz gut antrainiert, dass ich hoffentlich meistens trotzdem zuhöre. Du merkst ja in der Ligatur auch manchmal, ich mache irgendwas nebenbei und dann kommt, dann erzählst du halt, was weiß ich, Christian Bernhardt, irgendwas davon und dann muss ich immer grinsen. Oder mich reißt es halt sofort, wenn ich denke, nein, wenn du es willst. Den schätzt du völlig falsch.
Aber da sind wir ja schon beim Punkt. Also erstmal habe ich krassen Etikettenschwindel betrieben, denn ich habe euch vor der Sendung gesagt, also wir reden am Anfang ein bisschen über das Buch und jetzt sind wir schon eine ganze Weile drin und haben es noch nicht angesprochen. Aber man hat ja jetzt auch schon gerade gemerkt an eurem Austausch, ihr kennt euch halt sehr gut und ihr seid schon sehr lange miteinander unterwegs. Und jetzt ist eben das Buch erschienen. Hoffentlich haben die TV im Himmel, mitgeschrieben mit Kai Psotter, ist erschienen bei Edelsports und natürlich können sich das die Hörerinnen und Hörer jetzt kaufen. Und die langweiligste aller Fragen, aber es ist auch glaube ich die erste, die auch alle Hörerinnen und Hörer haben, ist, warum gibt es dieses Buch über euch? Warum wolltet ihr das haben?
Es gab mal eine Phase, da haben wir mit Kai, wir haben einfach mal einen engeren Austausch mit ihm gehabt. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das recht ist, aber wir haben einfach einen engeren Austausch mit ihm gehabt. Und Uli hat ihm einfach mal die Geschichte dargelegt. Einfach mal erzählt, so war das, so ist es. Und diese Geschichte kennt keiner. Und diese Geschichte wabert noch irgendwo bei uns im Hinterkopf rum. Und wir wissen nicht genau, was wollen wir damit raus, wenn, ja, wie. Wir wollten bloß, dass du weißt, dass das interessant ist. Wenn wir zusammenarbeiten sollten, wenn irgendwie was kommt, das ist noch eine Geschichte, die haben wir.
Also eure Familiengeschichte.
Genau, unsere Familiengeschichte.
Denn jetzt kann man ja drüber reden.
Genau, jetzt kann man drüber reden. Sorry, ja, genau, denk wieder. Unsere Familiengeschichte. Dass wir vollweisen sind, dass wir unsere Eltern verloren haben. 1999 Schrägsticht 2002. Das heißt, ich war 13 und 15, Uli war alles minus 2.
11 und 13.
Genau. Und das heißt, das war so die Geschichte, die Uli ihm erzählt hat. Und er hat am Anfang natürlich nicht genau gewusst, wie war das und so weiter. Wir haben es ihm dann so ein bisschen erklärt, aber nur überrissen sei jetzt mal. Er hat die Geschichte aber nie losgelassen. Er ist nach, glaube ich, 2, 3 Jahren wieder auf uns zu gekommen und hat gesagt, ich lasse die Geschichte nicht los, Jungs, ihr müsst mich das aufschreiben lassen. Ich will das schreiben. Am Anfang haben wir gesagt nein, weil wir hatten schon mehrere Angebote von, jetzt musst du mir wiederhelfen, irgendwas mit Graf.
Da spielt ja keine Rolle.
Von irgendwelchen Senderformaten, die das wollten, TV-Formaten und so in einem Halbstundenformat. Das wollten wir da einfach, das ist nicht so ein Nachmittagsprogramm, das man nebenbei laufen lässt und danach kommt eine Talkshow. Sondern wir wollten das in einem sauberen Rahmen haben und wenn dann auch, auch da wieder detailliert oder gar nicht. Oder auf unsere Art und Weise oder gar nicht und in einem ordentlichen Rahmen. Und dann haben wir irgendwann mal gesagt, wir stimmen zu, mit ihm mal zu sprechen. Treffen uns mal, haben uns dann in seinem Büro getroffen und haben einfach mal so ein bisschen drüber gesprochen, wie das alles abgelaufen ist und wie wir uns fühlen. Und haben dann einfach gesagt, so wie er mit uns arbeitet, so wie er mit uns schreibt und wie er schreibt, so ist es glaube ich der richtige Rahmen, das weiterzuführen. Und wir wussten, dann habe ich auch schon gemerkt, dass es nicht einfach ist, da ist jemand gestorben und warum und jetzt seid ihr da, sondern es ist, ich will wissen wie. Also er ist wirklich tief reingegangen und das hat mir gefallen, dass ich wusste in dem Moment, das ist der Richtige dafür, weil es interessiert ihn und er will die Geschichte nicht einfach erzählen, um die Geschichte zu erzählen, sondern er will die Geschichte sauber erzählen und es hat ihn selbst interessiert, wie es war. Und dann hat er mich gehabt, weil ich wusste, es hat den richtigen Rahmen und es wird kein Sensationsbuch oder sonst irgendwas, sondern es kriegt den pietettvollen Rahmen, den es verdient hat.
Und warum habt ihr das so lange unter Verschluss gehalten, dass ihr Vollweisen seid?
Das haben wir gar nicht aktiv getan, glaube ich, sondern du musst es ja so überlegen und das kommt hoffentlich auch rüber im Buch. Das ist ja kein, das passiert ja nicht von heute auf morgen, dass du bekannt wirst in der Branche sozusagen, sondern du gehst da ja rein und du gehst halt Schritte. Und zunächst einmal ist es vergleichsweise intim, dass ja, an mancher Stelle wird man so umzingelt von diesem Thema, dass jemandem die Frage einfällt, naja, warum fährst du nicht nach Hause? Warum macht ihr da einen Premier League an Weihnachten zum Beispiel?
Hatt ich mal ganz explizit bei einem Kollegen, der hat mich wirklich festgenagelt, fahr jetzt nach Hause und klär das mit deinen Eltern, wortwörtlich. Okay, man kann alles klären. Und ich sag, es gibt da nichts zu klären oder sonstiges. Und der hat mich nicht mehr in Ruhe gelassen. Und ich hab gesagt, hey, stopp.
Ach krass, okay.
Und irgendwann gehst du in der Branche ein, zwei Schritte. Dann interessieren sich Medien, Medien vereinen. Und dann kommt so mal eine Frage, die ganz locker und nett gemeint ist. Und die ja bei hoffentlich den meisten Menschen nichts auslöst, weil sie gesunde lebende Eltern haben. Was passiert jetzt? Ihr habt beide jetzt 16 Uhr, lauft gegeneinander. Der eine hat das, der andere hat das. Oder früher bei getrennten Sendern sogar. Wer schaut was? Und dann kannst du in dem schriftlichen Interview noch mal nachwirken und sagen, du sei so lieb, lass es raus. Das mag mit einigen Medien gehen, mit anderen nicht, wie wir wissen. Und dann passiert das aber auch mal in der Live-Situation. So beginnt ja das Buch. Okay, wie verhalte ich mich dazu? Und für mich war es zumindest so, das glaube ich, sind wir auch wahnsinnig unterschiedlich am Ende, dass ich mich so von dieser Frage so umzingelt gefühlt habe. Und dass ich irgendwie gerne gehabt hätte, weil ich fest davon ausgehe, dass Menschen mich sehr viel besser verstehen würden, wenn sie wüssten. Dass ich gedacht habe, das würde mich befreien, wenn ich es aufschreibe. Das ist sozusagen der eigene Antrieb für das eigene wohl. Aber, und das ist auch kein ganz unwesentlicher Teil, als besagte Anfrage damals kam, da war ich noch Student sogar, hab schon vereinzelt irgendwas veröffentlicht, aber kein Mensch hatte auch nur ansatzweise einen Begriff des Namens. Und da ging es eher um die Geschichte als solche, also ohne jetzt irgendwie große Enthüllungen oder sonst was zu machen. Und ich bin seinerzeit da mit zu Fritz von Ton & Taxi schon gegangen und hab gesagt, du, es gab da die Anfrage und ich hab halt gedacht, der sagt mir sowieso, nee, lass gut sein, machst du nicht. Wir intern haben relativ schnell gewusst, wir machen es eh nicht. Aber ich habe es ihm gesagt und er hat gesagt, ja, aber was denn, wenn jemand da draußen ist, dem es genauso geht, vielleicht würde der Mut schöpfen und sagen, schau mal, man kann trotzdem studieren, man kann trotzdem eine Ausbildung machen, die Ausbildung beenden und dann doch noch studieren und so weiter und so weiter. Ja und dann hat er mir das so gesagt mit seiner ganzen Lebenserfahrung und so, mit all den Dingen, so wie er es dann halt auch macht, das hat nie aufgehört in mir zu arbeiten. Und das ist natürlich auch gar kein kleiner Teil dieses Buches, dass wir hoffen und glücklicherweise gibt es schon einzelne Zuschriften dazu, dass wir hoffen, dass auch das helfen wird, in Anführungszeichen. Oder einfach nur, für mich ist es ganz häufig so, in dem Moment, wo ich mich nicht so alleine mit einer Sache fühle, geht es mir schon mal besser. Und möglicherweise sind es nicht so viele. Also das ist damals, was uns der Redakteur von einem Sender sagte, erfinde niemanden, dem das so geht. Es wird schon ein paar geben. Es gibt sicher eine dunkel Ziffer, klar. Die findet man nicht so leicht. Aber egal, mögen es zwei sein, dann war das in Ordnung.
Bei mir war es auch mal so, also ich trage es schon ein bisschen mit mir rum. Ich bin jetzt auch nicht mit der Alljüngste. Ich hatte immer am Anfang das Gefühl, ihr seid beide jünger als ich, möchte ich hier kurz sagen.
Also ich verbitte mir solche Beschwerden über das eigene.
Du bist jetzt schon erfahren. Das ist schon in Ordnung.
Ich habe die Füchte öfter lange mit mir rumgetragen, hatte immer so das Gefühl, die Leute werden sich denken. Die Leute werden sich denken. Dann whatever. Und das hat mich dann immer so, die sollen aber nicht wissen, die sollen ja denken, ist alles normal. Und das war immer so, warum ich das Gefühl für mich hatte, ich muss das keinem erzählen, oder ich sollte das keinem erzählen, weil ich immer dachte, das macht bei den Leuten was auf. Dass die denken, du kommst aus einem schlimmen Umfeld, so quasi, daraus. Und ich hatte immer Angst, bin ich ganz ehrlich, früher. Und irgendwann habe ich gelernt, das ist überhaupt nicht so, du kannst nichts dafür, sondern es hat sich keiner ausgesucht. Meine Eltern haben uns das, was sie mitgegeben haben, mit besten Wissen und Gewissen gemacht und wir sind sehr, sehr stolz darauf, auf das, was sie uns mitgegeben haben. Und die waren in allen Belangen für uns da, das glaube ich hast du gelesen, in allen Belangen für uns da. Die haben uns alles ermöglicht, was irgendwie möglich war, ohne irgendwas vermissen zu lassen. Und darauf können wir stolz sein. Und dass die jetzt nicht mehr sind, haben sie sich nicht ausgesucht, haben wir uns auch nicht ausgesucht. Aber ich kann trotzdem stolz sein, auf das, was ich daraus gemacht habe. Und wieder Uli sagt, wenn da dann jemand, mir hat einer geschrieben, ich habe vor kurzem meinen Vater verloren. Und mir geht es genauso. Wer hat Ricardo Basile geschrieben? Ich habe vor kurzem meinen Vater verloren. Und es ist echt krass, euch jetzt zu lesen, dass ihr das auch habt. Und ich verstehe euch jetzt besser und wir verstehen uns jetzt besser. Und auch zum Beispiel bei einer Kollegin, die will es einen Namen nicht nennen, ich weiß nicht, ob das bei Ricardo bekannt ist, die hat es mir auch geschrieben. Es ist Wahnsinn. Und dann hilft dir das auch, weil du dann denkst, ich glaube, das ist auch da draußen, wenn da einer sitzt und sagt, ich habe gerade eine schwierige Phase, das war bei uns ja auch so logischerweise, ich habe gerade eine schwierige Phase, jetzt kommt das auch noch dazu, ich glaube, jetzt bin ich verloren. Nein, das bist du nicht. Es kommt darauf an, was du draus machst. Und es ist nicht immer einfach, etwas draus zu machen, aber es ist auch nicht das Ende. Und ich glaube, dass auch da der Punkt ist, unsere Eltern hätten gewollt, dass wir das Beste draus machen. Das ist bei jedem Elternteil so. Und deswegen, wenn ich da nur einen mitnehme, ich war gestern bei der besten Freundin meiner Oma, die hat damals gesagt, ihr müsst diese Geschichte mal aufschreiben, das ist mir immer moorgeblieben. Es wird auch nur einer Person helfen, dann war es das Ganze schon wert. Eine total fromme Frau, es geht nur um christliche Werte und so super süße Frau, ich liebe die, Uli auch. Die wusste davon nichts, ich bin gestern zu ihr gefahren und habe ihr das Buch gebracht. Ich habe gesagt, das ist nur, weil du damals gesagt hast. Die wäre fast aus den Wolken gefahren, fast angefangen zu weinen. Weil sie gesagt hat, dass du dich daran erinnerst und das gibt es ja nicht und wer hat das denn aufgeschrieben. Das ist natürlich schon eine ältere Dame mittlerweile, ist ja klar. Und die konnte es fast gar nicht fassen. Dann habe ich mir gedacht, ich glaube, wir haben das Richtige gemacht, weil es ist keine alltägliche Geschichte. Wir bilden uns darauf nichts ein, um Gottes Willen. Auch das wird wahrscheinlich der eine oder andere vermuten. Jetzt müssen die beiden auch noch ein Buch schreiben. Sondern ich glaube, es geht einfach darum, das sachlich mal runtergeschrieben zu haben, das Erbe unserer Eltern so würdig wie möglich aufgeschrieben zu haben, das Vermächtnis unserer Eltern auch noch mal quasi um fünf Ecken Danke zu sagen, für das, was die für uns gemacht haben und das einfach dann vielleicht mal lieber zu schreiben, sollte uns mal was passieren, wie auch immer. Dass unsere, dass seine Tochter, sein Sohn, wie auch immer, vielleicht habe ich auch mal, verstehen, wo wir herkommen, wieso, weshalb, warum. Weil ja auch da, der Stammbaum ist jetzt auch nicht mehr so dicht bewachsen, das muss man auch langsam mal sagen. Irgendwann versteht es dann, versteht es nicht mehr jeder, wo kommen wir her. Und jetzt glaube ich, es ist einmal mal sachlich aufgeschrieben und jeder versteht ungefähr, so ticken die beiden. Und es gibt natürlich nicht nur den Strang, sondern es gibt ja auch dann noch, wie sind wir in die Branche gekommen, was ist in der Branche passiert und so weiter und so fort. Es gibt ein paar, da kommt ja dann deine musikalische Vergangenheit auf ein Spiel. Wir haben auch eine musikalische Vergangenheit. Es kommen so viele Sachen, glaube ich, es ist für jeden was dabei. Der eine wird lachen, der andere wird weinen. Viele haben mir geschrieben, die haben geweint, mein bester Kumpel hat geweint, der das Wort Tränen nicht mehr buchstabieren kann. Also es ist, glaube ich, für jeden was dabei wirklich. Und man kann sich die Kapitel auch aussuchen, wie man dann überspringen möchte.
Man wird es eh von Anfang bis Ende lesen. Das habe ich ja auch so gemacht. Ich habe es ja als einer der ersten bekommen.
Du warst der Erste Externe, der es bekommen hat. Und ich darf auch da spoilern oder darf es erklären. Ich habe es dir um 16.15 Uhr gebracht. Ich weiß es nämlich noch genau, weil es war Halbzeit im Bundesliga. Deswegen wusste ich, dass du da zu Hause bist. Das war alles ausgerechnet. Ich dachte, ich muss jetzt noch hinfahren, weil jetzt ist er zu Hause. Nicht, dass der da nicht mehr da ist. Du hast mir um 22.30 Uhr oder 23.30 Uhr irgendetwas geschrieben. Ich bin jetzt durch mit dem Buch. Ich konnte nicht mehr aufhören. Das ist ein sehr großes Lob, nicht an mich oder uns, sondern an Kai Psotter, der das einfach sehr gut geschrieben hat. Ich muss wirklich sagen.
Ich habe es wirklich sehr gerne gelesen. Ich hatte irgendwie wieder meine sechs, sieben Spiele geguckt an dem Tag und ich brauche dann was, was nicht Bildschirm ist. Ansonsten komme ich nicht runter. Das kennt ihr ja auch, dass man einfach auch nach Sendung und so weiter. Da habe ich das ganz entspannt.
Das ist jetzt kein Lobweiß im Zweifel nach einem Bundesliga-Wochenende. Das ist alles weniger langweilig.
Aber gleichzeitig macht ihr euch damit ja auch verletzlich. Und das tut ihr ja in einer Branche, die jetzt nicht dafür bekannt ist, einen Ellbogeneinsatz zu sparen. Und es gibt nur wenige Kometatoren Plätze, auf die viele wollen. Welche Rolle hat denn das gespielt?
Der Ellbogeneinsatz wird nur selten abgefiffen.
Ja, genau.
Ganz ehrlich, den Satz habe ich ein paar Mal jetzt auch im Privaten gesagt, zu Vertrauten, zu meinem Bruder auch. Und wer darauf in Anführungszeichen neidisch ist, auf diese Aufmerksamkeit, dass er dieses Buch hätte schreiben können, was soll ich dem helfen? Der hat andere Schwierigkeiten, weil...
Ich hätte lieber die Geschichte nicht, das ist am Ende eine Entscheidung, die für uns, glaube ich, die Schwierigste war und ist. Öffnet man sich so sehr, in welcher Form tut man das, aber überwiegend tut am Ende, glaube ich, der Nutzen in Anführungszeichen für uns, dass ich mir dadurch erhoffe, und bei mir selbst hat es schon mal funktioniert. Ich habe, ich selber habe vieles gelernt in dem Buch. Ich habe ein Buch über mich, ich habe Dinge noch mal einfach chronologisch gehabt. Das ist jetzt mal so der ganz sachliche Teil der ganzen Veranstaltungen, wie ich das in dem Buch versuche auch zu beschreiben. Ich habe irgendwann im Verlauf meines Lebens gemerkt, mir geht es einfach sehr viel besser, wenn ich mich mitteile. Das habe ich hiermit getan und jetzt kann jeder draus machen, was er will. Ich glaube, dass manchmal empfinden Menschen Grenzen, wenn sie mit mir sprechen, die ich aber gar nicht so einfach aufziehen möchte. Und jetzt wissen sie es sehr viel besser, wenn sie sich damit beschäftigen. Und das ist, wie immer in meinem ganzen Leben oder in unserem ganzen Leben, von jedem, wenn immer du genau gelesen wirst, ist das ein unheimliches Privileg, weil Menschen haben wenig Zeit und viel, viel Angebot. Und das ist etwas, wenn das jemand tut, wenn er sich jemand damit auseinandersetzt, dann finde ich das wahnsinnig toll, schön. Und das ist sozusagen der Grund. Und jetzt ist es draußen, was andere damit machen, das obliegt ihnen.
Aber das wäre auch tatsächlich, hätte eigentlich die zweite Frage dieses Gesprächs sein sollen. Erste, warum das Buch? Jetzt kommen wir zur zweiten Frage. Was habt ihr über das eigene Leben gelernt?
Genau, das ist der Punkt, auf den ich jetzt auswähle. Sehr viel, weil wir gemerkt haben, es gibt, es gibt unterschiedliche Erinnerungen. Ganz einfach. Ich habe manche Dinge nicht abgespeichert, die Uli abgespeichert. Und er hat manche Dinge nicht abgespeichert, die ich abgespeichert. Allein das Auszug, das hätten wir niemals gemacht, uns hinzusetzen, ja weißt du noch, wann das war oder weißt du noch, wie das war? Das macht man ja eigentlich auch nicht. Ich glaube, du kommst aus dem Hollen nicht mehr raus, wenn du einfach in diesen Sog da mal rein bist. Ich habe es Kai erzählt und Kai sagt, dein Bruder sagt aber. Und dann sage ich, was, wirklich, echt? Und dann sind wir ins Gespräch gekommen, das wusste ich gar nicht mehr. Es gab Dinge, die hätte ich gar nicht mehr erfragt, weil ich gar nicht mehr gewusst hätte, dass sie erfragt, dass das überhaupt passiert ist. Das war nicht so, dass ich noch irgendwie einen Trauma habe. Das waren so Kleinigkeiten, zum Beispiel, jetzt wird es dann wirklich deep, als der Uli erzählt hat, zum Beispiel, Mama wurde die Brust amputiert und sie ist mit einer Perücke nur noch durchs Haus. Und in dem Moment, ich wusste das nicht mehr. Und zwar nicht, weil ich es vergessen hatte oder so, sondern ich habe das einfach in eine Schublade gesteckt. Es gibt Menschen, die verarbeiten das so. Die packen Dinge in eine Schublade und es wird zugesperrt. In dem Moment, als der Uli das aber sagt, ist die Schublade aufgegangen und ich hatte das ganze Pergament, das ist rausgerollt und ich habe alles wieder gesehen. Innerhalb von drei Sekunden war das für mich. Mir wurde heiß, kalt, warm, alles gleichzeitig. Krass, das ist alles passiert. Stimmt und ich habe das komplett ignoriert, einfach ausgeblendet. Und das ist der Punkt, in dem du auch drin bist, dass du für dich selbst nochmal das Ganze aufarbeitest und sagst, okay, so war das. Das wusste ich gar nicht mehr. Ich verstehe.
Aber was habt ihr über euch gelernt? Also ihr könnt jetzt quasi so offen sein, wie ihr wollt. Das ist hier weiter euer Rahmen. Aber ich stelle mir das so vor, also ich möchte das nicht vergleichen, aber nur quasi daneben stellen. Bei mir war es ja so, dass bei mir es sehr, sehr früh im Leben der Zwillinge eine Trennung gab und ich dann dieses Wechselmodell hatte. Und ich musste ganz früh die Entscheidung treffen, wird das im Rasenfunk stattfinden? Ja oder nein. Und weil ich aber schon sehr früh abschätzen konnte, vor allem als die Zwillinge noch so klein waren, dass das immer wieder den Rasenfunk betreffen wird, also Sendungen werden ausfallen, ich konnte mal eine Sendung nicht fertig machen und so weiter und so fort, habe ich das thematisiert. Und dann gab es eben auch einmal eine Podcastfolge beim Bayerischen Rundfunk Eltern ohne Filter. Da habe ich dann einmal erzählt, ohne zu erzählen, was passiert ist, weil es geht auch niemandem was an und wäre auch ungerecht, ehrlich gesagt, wenn da nur ich drüber rede. Aber habe ich einfach die Situation erzählt, um das quasi so einmal einfach gesagt zu haben und dann kannst du immer darauf referieren. Und es war auch interessant, was ich da dann für ein Feedback bekommen habe. Aber bei mir war es wirklich interessant, dass ich, obwohl ich nichts anderes getan habe, als über meine Situation nachzudenken, mit einem Dritten, der nicht beteiligt ist, drüber sprechen. Ich habe noch mal Sachen über mich gelernt und ich bin quasi nach diesem Interview schon leicht anders gewesen als vorher. Geht euch das auch so?
Klar, es ist ja allein schon wie, ich habe dann mal so auch so wirklich versucht mal, wie beschreibt Kai mich, wie beschreibt Kai Uli. Und das ist dann schon so, dass du dir denkst, so bin ich, krass, also sieht der das wirklich so? Oder das ist ja ganz normal, dass du natürlich dann auch etwas über dich lernst. Und wir haben die Geschichte schon, ich habe die Geschichte schon tausendmal erzählt. Natürlich, Leuten, wenn irgendjemand gefragt hat, wie geht es deinen Eltern, was machen die eigentlich? Du datest jemanden, keine Ahnung, was machen deine Eltern eigentlich? Dann sagst du halt, hm, schwierig oder so. Du versuchst, ich habe dann mittlerweile 17 Ausfahrten, die ich fahre. Irgendwann sagt aber jemand, du hast 17 Mal die Ausfahrt genommen. Jetzt will ich wissen, was ist los? Dann kommst du nicht mehr aus. Und du hast die Geschichte schon 30.000 Mal erzählt. Nur, was ich bei mir gemerkt habe, ist, dass ich in dieser Situation halt einfach ein Programm abspule. Weil es für mich einfach, ich kenne es schon. Und ich will mich auch in dem Moment nicht emotional zeigen und nicht zu viel preisgeben. Markus Land hat das mal gesagt, finde ich einen sehr, sehr guten Punkt. Er hat mal gesagt, Leute, die ihre Eltern verloren haben und die das vielleicht auch nicht so leicht hatten, damit umzugehen, die tendieren dazu, eine Maske aufzusetzen und es zu überspielen. Das finde ich ein sehr, sehr gutes Bild. Weil ich mich in dem Moment, als er das gesagt hat, genau da wiedergefunden habe. Da hast du ab und zu einfach gute Mine. Und es redet um eine Rede zu dir. Und du würdest am liebsten sagen, das war das Schlimmste, was einem Menschen passieren kann, weil das sehr wichtige, also die wichtigsten Menschen in unserem Leben waren, ist ja klar. Und das war alles andere als einfach. Aber du, du, du sagst, du erzählst es ja nicht jedem so, sondern du sagst natürlich ja, und das war natürlich nicht einfach. Und was das ist, muss ja auch nicht jeder. Kannst du nicht bei jedem das Fass aufmachen. Und dass ich da einfach wirklich die Maske auf absetzen konnte und sagen konnte, es war so und es war einfach schrecklich so. Und es erzählen konnte, wie es war und wie ich mich gefühlt habe und warum und weshalb. Und das hat mir sehr geholfen, damit auch nochmal besser umzugehen und selber zu verstehen, was da eigentlich passiert ist. Weil du erzählst die Geschichte 30.000 Mal und irgendwann spult es einfach dein Unterbewusstsein nur noch ab, in Anführungszeichen. Und das einfach wirklich nochmal sich vor Augen zu führen, was da passiert ist und wie... Du merkst dann auch, wie Leute reagieren. Also die ersten Reaktionen waren natürlich, boah, wenn es mit meinen Eltern passiert wäre, dann siehst du erst mal, wie schlimm das glaube ich ist, was da passiert ist. Aber du bist es halt schon gewohnt, das alles nochmal wirklich so vor deinem Auge zu führen. Boah, das war echt heftig und das war so. Und da habe ich so reagiert und stimmt, ja. Das hat mir persönlich geholfen, weil ich sonst dazu tendiert hätte, dass ich immer wieder beim Schließfach, ich hätte das weggepackt.
Ja gut, das ist ja wirklich bei so traumatischen Erfahrungen eigentlich so der Klassiker. Aber sei froh, dass du die Schublade jetzt aufgemacht hast, denn irgendwann in deinem Leben wäre sie ansonsten aufgegangen. Das kann ich nur allen empfehlen, die irgendeinen Traum haben, was sie noch nicht therapeutisch aufgearbeitet haben. Macht es lieber. Es ist einfacher, als wenn ihr es dann zwangsweise machen müsst, weil ihr ja was auch immer dann bei euch passiert ist. Aber Uli, wie ist das bei dir? Hast du das Gefühl, es wird so quasi vor dem Buch und nach dem Buch geben?
Für mich selbst ja. Von außen ist mir burscht, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Aber für mich selbst ja, weil ich schon... Also bei mir ist es ganz anders. Es gibt so ein paar generelle Dinge und es gibt ein paar ganz spezifische Dinge. Zum einen haben wir uns als Brüder jeden Tag stundenlang sehr zum Leid wissen, meiner Freundin, manchmal zur Freude meiner Kinder, viel zu sagen. Haben aber über ganz viele Dinge trotzdem auch nicht gesprochen, nicht so tief gesprochen. Und manchmal wusste ich gar nicht, was denkt er eigentlich über die Situation, wie ich mich damals verhalten habe und sicherlich auch andersrum. Und Kai, und das mag ich so an ihm, hat uns immer schön gespiegelt. Es war echt nicht ganz unlehrreich. Und dann gibt es so spezielle Dinge. Mir war gar nicht klar, wie sehr ich zum Beispiel die Episoden zwischen den Kreuzbandrissen einfach verdränge.
Also man muss dazu sagen, du hattest drei Kreuzbandrissen.
Insgesamt sogar vier, noch eine am rechten, aber die hat nichts mehr zur Sache getan, weil da war es eh schon vorbei.
Das heißt, ihr habt einen Kreuzbandriss noch rausgelassen?
Ja, ja den haben wir. Ja, by the way, das ist dasselbe. Für uns ist das ja quasi normal. Und es gibt eine Episode im Buch, wo wir in England sind, das erste Mal. Hat wahnsinnig lang gedauert, bis wir, also ich vor allen Dingen, du warst ein bisschen früher dran, du warst vom Alter her wahrscheinlich ähnliches, das erste Mal geflogen sind. Und dann waren wir in England und dann Kai hat mir gesagt, ja was hast du alles? Und dann habe ich ihm alles mögliche geschickt, Bilder, da haben wir uns 18.000 Fußballartikel gekauft, das ganze Bett voll gemacht, waren total stolz, haben die Bargains gehunted und so. Und irgendwann habe ich ihm gesagt, so ja, da habe ich sogar noch die Zeitung, kann dir genau reproduzieren, wo das herkommt. Und da war, und deswegen haben wir uns die gekauft, Stabbing in, also Messerstecherei beim Unboxing-Dape vor diesem Masseneinkaufstag. Und dann hat Kai nur zu mir gesagt, Wahnsinn, erzähl mir mehr. Dann habe ich gesagt, ok, was ist daran jetzt so spannend? Und ich konnte mich noch relativ genauer an den Satz des Polizisten erinnern, an den ich ganz, ganz oft denke, wenn was Tragisches passiert, it's not about you, hab mal ein bisschen Respekt, da ist gerade was passiert. Nicht dir, sondern denen. Und dann hat er gesagt, das ist so, das macht mich so traurig, dass ihr selbst, wenn irgendwann mal was Positives passiert, wird es euch sofort wieder versaut. Und das war mir aber so gar nicht klar, weil ich gar nicht so durchs Leben laufe, hoffentlich zumindest, meistens nicht. Das habe ich gelernt. Ich habe aber auch noch mal gecheckt, wenn du das alles so aufschreibst, obwohl mir das nie nicht bewusst war, wie viele Leute einem geholfen haben auf dem Weg dahin, im privaten, im beruflichen. Hoffentlich konnten wir all die Blumen verteilen, die wir verteilen wollten. Da sagt der dann manchmal auch ein Autor, ja, aber schon wieder einen einführen, der nichts zur Sache tut und so. Und dadurch, dass es für mich sehr viel klarer geworden ist, vieles viel klarer geworden ist, auch im zeitlichen Kontext noch mal klarer geworden ist, ist das wieso, das ist jetzt auf einer Festplatte abgespeichert und ist da. Und jetzt habe ich das Gefühl, ich weiß, am Ende werden keine Ahnung, von zehn Menschen, denen ich begegne, werden es neun, drei Viertel nicht gelesen haben oder noch nie davon gehört haben. Trotzdem habe ich das Gefühl, ich muss jetzt nicht mehr lügen, sondern ich kann sagen, wenn ich jemanden treffe, war gestern im Zug so, der fragt und dann kann man sagen, du, da gibt es ein Buch drüber, deswegen kann ich es dir auch sagen, weil ich muss es nicht mehr verstecken. Und das alleine reicht mir schon.
Und dann ist es ja, und das macht ja das Buch, also eröffnet den Kontext noch so, gleichzeitig sagt es auch ein bisschen was über die verschiedenen Wege, die es in den Journalismus geben kann. Und an das, zu den Positionen, zu denen ihr jetzt gekommen seid, man versteht sehr viel besser, warum ihr diese irre enge Bindung habt. Also das merkt ja jeder, der auch nur irgendwie mit euch zu tun hat, dass es diese enge Bindung gibt, aber wir finden alle super, wie wir wissen.
Ich habe schon meinen Satz gehört von jemandem, ich weiß nicht, ob es die Person, wer sie nennt, aber ob die zitiert hat oder ob das ihr Zitat ist von dieser Person, ja die sind ja immer zu zweit. Das haben die eher bedrohlich gefunden quasi. Die haben schon einen Spieler mehr auf dem Feld in dieser Branche. Ich sehe das nicht so, dass ich jemandem was wegnehmen müsste und weggrätschen müsste, sondern wie du gerade wahrscheinlich auch dargelegt haben, wir versuchen einfach unser Ding gut zu machen. Und wenn es jemand findet, dann wählt er mich und nicht jemand anderen. Aber ich habe keinen Bock, den anderen wegzudrücken. Das bringt mir nichts. Also zumindest mir macht es keinen Spaß und ich bin auch nicht gut drin.
Ja gut, aber ihr seid halt dieses Zweier-Team. Ja, das stimmt. Das fällt halt extrem auf in einer Branche, in der viele für sich alleine arbeiten. Und jeder baut sich zwar so sein Avengers-Team zusammen. Also das, was ihr mit Fritz von Turn und Taxis zum Beispiel habt, das haben andere KommentatorInnen, haben das auch. Das weiß ich ja auch, dass du dann, du hast, wenn ich dann frage, auf wen hörst du eigentlich, dann sagen dir die Leute aus der Pistole geschossen zwei, drei Namen, oft von anderen Kolleginnen, wo sie sagen, wenn die mir was sagen, dann nehme ich es auch ernst, alles andere muss ich ausblenden. Und deswegen fällt das aber halt einfach so auf, weil ihr halt einfach so oft zu zweit seid in eurem Podcast, weil ihr es beide auch geschafft habt. Und das ist ja eigentlich auch total unwahrscheinlich, dass ihr beide im selben Job gelandet seid.
Ja, das alleine wäre fast schon ein Buch, ne?
Eigentlich auch wieder nichts, wenn du dann wieder das Buch liest. Allein eigentlich auch wieder nichts, weil es war immer so, dass wir am Bolzplatz, wir hatten immer dieselben Hobbys, egal was ich gemacht habe, Uli hat, teilweise ich ja nicht, dass ich jetzt irgendwie first through the wall bin, weil ich der Beste bin oder so. Ich war der Erste. Ich habe dann einfach mit dem Nachbarn zuerst ein Panini-Album bekommen, was ist ich? Und dann sagt Uli, ich will auch eins. Und so war es immer. Das ist ja auch ganz normal. Dann war es irgendwo in der Freundeskreis, dann hatte der ein Trikot von Dahm mehr, dann hatte der andere ein Trikot. Muss ich auch. Ich habe gestern gesagt, Uli hat ein Trikot aus Argentinien, Bocca Juniors, dann wollte ich eins aus Brasilien, war es Kodagama. Mir reicht es jetzt. Der wird es schon sehen. Das ist halt ganz normal. Und dann ist ja irgendwie klar, dass du dich dann irgendwann hochschaukelst und hochschaukelst und hochschaukelst. Und da wir die gleichen Interessen hatten und ich irgendwann mal dann da reingerutscht bin irgendwie in diesen Studiengang. Man hat Uli gemerkt, dass es für ihn auch was und dann hat es sich dann einfach so hoch multipliziert, sage ich jetzt einmal mal. Und deswegen ja, irgendwie ist es total unwahrscheinlich. Aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn du es jetzt wieder nachzeigst, dann die haben eigentlich den ganzen Tag nur über Fußball geredet und nur mit allen, nur Trikots und nur FIFA und nur Pornini-Bilder und nur den ganzen Tag, wer kennt mehr Spieler, irgendwie ist es dann auch wieder nicht unwahrscheinlich. Also irgendwie schon, weil natürlich der Weg dahin nicht so leicht ist. Aber wenn du die Wurzel nimmst und sagst, also was hätten die beiden sonst eigentlich gekonnt? Nix. Also ich kann nichts anderes als Fußball den ganzen Tag. Es ist einfach so.
Ja, lustig. Das wäre eine der Fragen gewesen, was ihr gemacht hättet, wenn ihr nicht Kommentatoren gewonnen werdet. Aber so ein bisschen Eindruck bekommt man ja auch, wenn man dieses Buch dann liest. Gleichzeitig ist es so, also es gab ja quasi schon einen beruflichen hohe Höhepunkt, bei dem die Frage ist, ist es ein vorläufiger Höhepunkt. Uli, du hast das Champions-League-Finale kommentiert. Wo wollt ihr denn eigentlich noch hin?
In den Rasenfunk wieder.
Das ist gar kein Problem. Die Tür steht euch immer offen. Aber vielleicht noch was mit Reichweite, dachte ich.
Ja, du hast das so, Freunde.
Also, um ehrlich zu sein, die Frage habe ich mir selber vor allen Dingen oft gestellt. Ich habe sie aber auch gestellt bekommen und dann weiß ich, ich habe einen guten Freundeskreis, wenn die relativ schnell sagen, übrigens, nicht runterfallen jetzt, sondern mal vorbereitet darauf, dass es auch eine Gefahr hat, wenn man sein Ziel erreicht, sein eigentlich unmögliches Ziel, wenn man so will. Und das Gute ist, dass ich so sehr an meiner, also gar nicht jetzt Selbstoptimierung im psychologischen Sinne, sondern an meiner Kommentatorenpersönlichkeit, Selbstoptimierung, langes Wort, aber ich glaube, einigermaßen sinnvoll, so sehr interessiert bin, dass das nicht schlimm ist. Ob ich jetzt noch mal mache oder nicht, also ich hätte jetzt auch nichts dagegen, wenn ich es noch mal repliziere, ist aber okay, wenn es nicht mehr passiert. Es gibt noch ein Thema, das ich lange auf dem Schirm hatte, was noch so auf der Bucketlist liegt, das werde ich demnächst erreichen. Schön. Und daher bin ich eigentlich sehr zufrieden. Schön, das sagen zu können. Alles gut. Es gibt dann noch so, klar, wir wollen logisch mit dem Podcast noch, ich hätte nichts dagegen, wenn wir zwei als Brüder, was eigentlich so sinnvoll wäre, du hast ja gesagt, das ist eigentlich unwahrscheinlich. Per se ist das fast schon ein Buch. Warum zwei Brüder? Das gab es halt noch nicht. Meiner Meinung nach gibt es das auch nicht. Es gibt die Töpperwins, die auf unterschiedlichen Positionen, okay, das war es aber schon. Das wäre super sinnvoll und ich hätte da natürlich nichts dagegen, wenn wir das eingespielte Team, das wir sind, auch auf Sendung sein könnten. Warum denn nicht? Wir sind es im Podcast, es macht Spaß. Es wäre sinnvoll, das im Kommentar zu etablieren, aus meiner Sicht, aber das entscheide ich nicht.
Gab es ja auch schon. Ja, zwei, drei Mal, glaube ich, müsste es gegeben haben.
Aber ja, müsste sich doch...
Moment mal, und die Küppers machen das doch auch?
Ja, Vater und Sohn, ja genau.
Gut, den naheliegenden Witz habe ich jetzt liegen lassen, den mache ich jetzt nicht. Es gibt auch noch ein anderes Vater und Sohn, du das aber nicht.
Das wurde der Witz vor allem verantwortlich letztens auch gebracht.
Ja, genau.
Ja, okay. Aber wo willst du denn noch hin, Jogi? Also ich frage mich eben, das Interessante ist ja, ihr seid ja noch jung und es kann noch sehr viel passieren. Ja, ich weiß, dass sich das für uns alle anders anfühlt. Ich werde jetzt auch bald 41, aber alle...
Ja, aber für den Kommentator natürlich schon. Mir wurde gesagt, auf so einer Position beendet man seine Karriere, man beginnt sie nicht. Bei uns war es ja glücklicherweise umgekehrt, wenn man ehrlich ist.
Genau, und gleichzeitig ist es ja aber auch so, euer Tätigkeitsbereich, der ist aktuell, wenn man jetzt einfach mal vom Fußball ausgeht, relativ begrenzt. Es gibt eine definierte Anzahl an Sendern, es gibt eine definierte Anzahl an TV-Rechten. Ihr habt einen der ganz wenigen Jobs, das hat Benni Zander mal irgendwann bei Twitter geschrieben. TV-Kommentator ist einer der wenigen Jobs, wo man aus der Presse erfährt, ob man nächste Saison noch einen Job hat, weil die TV-Rechte an anderen Sender vergeben werden. Da gibt es ja eigentlich gar nicht mehr so viele Möglichkeiten sich zu entwickeln. Deswegen frage ich eben, wo würdest du gerne noch hin?
Es gibt mehrere Stränge. Bei Sky zum Beispiel würde ich gerne Match of the Week nochmal machen. Das haben wir schon gemacht, aber natürlich würde ich es gerne öfter machen. Das Topspiel der Premier League jede Woche zu machen, ist natürlich etwas, was erstrebenswert ist, das jede Woche wiederzumachen. Aber es gibt den einen Punkt, das habe ich kein letztens auch gesagt, es gibt schon ein Ding, das mir immer noch so auf der Schulter sitzt. Und das wäre einfach ein WM-Spiel. Weil das erste, was ich damals, warum ich mich in Fußball verliebt war, habe, verliebt war, ist auch gut, da sind wir wieder bei deinem grammatischen, grammatikalischen... Nächster, Nächster, siehst du schon, es geht los, egal.
Die Sendung ist schon lang.
Wir kommen daraus. Das war damals die WM 94. Und das war damals der Startschuss. Da habe ich mich damals verliebt, Panini-Bilder. Wir haben diesen blöden Hund da, der auf diesen T-Shirts überall drauf war. Den habe ich überall drauf gehabt. Und das wäre einfach nur mein Ziel. Und das irgendwie hinzukriegen wäre ein Traum. Deswegen muss ich auf jeden Fall kein Finale sein. Da würde mir auch schon reichen, einfach zu sagen, wow.
Ich meine, das Interessante ist ja, man kann in dem Bereich nicht seine Ziele alle erreichen. In der Regel zumindest. Denn wir sind hier schon...
Wolfsfuß ist glaube ich ziemlich nah.
Ja, genau. Aber das wäre jetzt genau nämlich mein Beispiel gewesen. Da gibt es nämlich durchaus eine Parallele zum Leistungssport. Es gibt einen FC Bayern, das ist halt im Kommentatorenbereich aktuell Wolfsfuß. Und der hat alles tausendmal schon durchgespielt. Und wird das auch noch hundertmal machen, weil er einfach er selbst ist. Und das ist das, was gerade gefragt ist. Aber es kann ja nicht jeder ein WM-Spiel kommentieren. Das wird nicht jeder erreichen können. Das heißt, an irgendeinem Punkt muss man eine Grundzufriedenheit erreichen, die aber nicht in Zynismus oder Resignation oder so mitn darf, wo es ja ehrlicherweise auch Kollegen gibt, wo man das manchmal ja auch an der Arbeit letztlich merkt. Und was auch verständlich ist, also ich will es nicht verurteilen, es ist völlig normal, wenn du quasi, du kommst über einen gewissen Punkt nicht raus, du darfst immer nur das Real Life Augsburg Spiel bei der Zone machen. Das nervt irgendwann und das geht jetzt nicht gegen Augsburg, nicht gegen der Zone und nicht gegen Real Life.
Also ich hab mal zu meinem, mein Chef hat damals gesagt, ja du bist ja immer vorbereitet, bla, bla, bla. Dann hab ich gesagt, du, ich wollte, dass das Kind immer werden. Ich werde jetzt nicht anfangen aufzuhören, niemals. Sondern ich mach weiter und irgendwann wird es jemand erkennen oder auch nicht. Wenn nicht, ich war schon immer, ich war noch nie LeBron James, auf den alle 13 Jahre gewartet haben, bis der endlich 16 ist und jetzt dürfen sie ihn unterschreiben lassen. Das war ich noch nie. Sondern ich musste immer 13 mal anklopfen und es hat irgendwann geklappt. Ich war wahrscheinlich im Vergleich mit anéer Antoine Semenyo oder so was, der schon fast aufhören wollte, so gefühlt. Natürlich nicht, aber ich bin immer drangeblieben, hab es mir irgendwann erarbeitet. Und das wird sich auch nicht ändern. Natürlich ist das manchmal so, dass wir am Telefon sind und sagen, boah, ich hätte auch gerne oder ich würde auch gerne oder ich hab doch, das ist ganz normal. Jeder hat das doch ganz normal. Du würdest auch wahrscheinlich sagen, ich hätte ganz gerne auch das, was die anderen haben. Jeder schaut immer mal aufs andere Feld. Das ist ganz normal. Aber grundsätzlich sitze ich und das habe ich sehr, sehr häufig, den Moment, dass ich im Auto sitze und mir denke, es ist einfach nur geil, dass du das machen darfst. Weil gestern der Mann der besten Freunde meiner Oma meinte, es ist immer Gnade, wenn du das machen darfst, was du liebst. Und das stimmt. Und deswegen habe ich es sehr, sehr oft, dass ich im Auto sitze, Musik höre und mir dann denke, es ist einfach geil, dass du das machen darfst. Dass du jetzt hier Manchester City gegen Manchester United machen darfst. Manchmal schreibe ich das dann auch nieder und habe je letzten Tag gepostet, das war ein Spiel, da habe ich, als ich 2013 Volo war bei Sky Sparadius, mir gedacht, wow, das ist Meilen weit entfernt, bis es im gleichen Haus dann passiert, aber halt 10 Jahre später oder so. Oder 13 Jahre später. Das ist dann einfach so eine Fügung, die es manchmal gibt und dann freust du dich darüber und denkst dir, wow, das ist unglaublich. In dem Moment begreifst du es und ich werde dann manchmal auch sentimental denken, mir ist es einfach cool, dass du es machen darfst, schreibe es dann nieder und dann ist es für mich auch wieder gut. Ich lasse mich dann nicht davon wegtragen. Ich glaube, das ist das, worauf du nachdenken willst. Das darfst du halt nicht. Dann einfach sagen sie quasi, ah, ich habe jetzt eine Champions-League-Finale kommentiert, jetzt brauche ich nichts mehr machen. Das darfst du nicht machen, du darfst aber auch nicht machen. Ich kriege Champions-League-Finale nicht, also könnt ihr mich jetzt alle mal. Das darfst du auch nicht, sondern du musst einfach, wenn du tue genug Gutes und es wird dir auch Gutes wiederfahren. Arbeite hart dran, dann kriegst du es. Wenn nicht, dann nicht. Dann war ich Rang 7 in der Tabelle und kann trotzdem am Ende des Tages sagen, wenn ich irgendwann mal umfahren sollte, ich habe eigentlich genau den Job gehabt, den ich immer haben wollte. Und das können auch nicht so viele behaupten, weil ich glaube, auch meine Eltern haben das nicht gehabt zum Beispiel. Bei denen war es einfach nur, die haben gesagt, mein Papa wollte andere Sachen machen, das weiß ich. Aber die haben das Haus damals einfach nicht abzahlen können, andersherum haben sie sich da in diesem Chemiebetrieb einschreiben lassen quasi. Das war es. Es gibt Leute, die haben das nicht, die machen es dann für andere Dinge. Es gibt auch Leute, die sagen, ich mache einfach meinen Job gerne, weil ich oder ich mache meinen Job einfach und mir ist es egal. Ich will einfach meinen Urlaub finanzieren. Hab ja auch einen Kollegen gehabt, der das gesagt hat. Ist auch cool. Jeder kann das. Aber deswegen umso glücklicher und dankbarer können wir sein, dass wir das machen dürfen. Es ist nicht immer nur Zuckerschlecken. Es ist nicht jedes Spiel schön. Es ist nicht jede Ansetzung schön. Es ist nicht jedes Spiel vorzubereiten einfach. Das ist ja ganz normal. Aber wenn ich dann Pound-vor-Pound vergleiche, haben wir es sehr gut erwischt und können sehr froh sein, das machen zu dürfen.
Und was hättet ihr gerne am Beginn eures Weges gewusst? Also ich meine jetzt, als ihr dann quasi so ins Berufsleben gestartet seid, und das kann man ja hier nachlesen, es war jeweils keine gerade Linie, sondern da mussten gewisse Dinge passen und ihr wart auch manchmal zur richtigen Zeit am richtigen Ort. Das ist eben einfach das Glück, was man im Leben manchmal braucht. Uli, was hättest du gerne am Anfang dieses Weges gewusst, was du jetzt weißt?
Es geht nicht nur um Inhalt. Es geht nicht darum, dass du der beste Kommentator bist, oder der beste Journalist, oder dass du dich möglichst maximal vorbereitest, sondern es geht auch um Marketing. Und das habe ich nicht gecheckt.
Die Moment blindet einen.
Ja, genau, guter Mann. Shoutout hat mir Sebastian Kneizel sehr viel geholfen und mir das sehr viel und sehr früh gesagt. Er hat eine wunderschöne Metapher gewählt, dass er gesagt hat, wenn du ein Weltklasse-Spieler sein willst auf dem Platz, dann brauchst du vieles. Du hast vielleicht den besten rechten Fuß auf der Welt, aber ohne linken wird es nichts werden. Und jetzt ist es Zeit, deinen linken zu trainieren.
Und dann bist du zu Instagram.
Bitte?
Und dann bin ich zu Instagram.
Da haben wir uns noch drüber unterhalten, das weiß ich noch.
Genau. Ja, genau. Gut, ja, gut. Sehr gut. Ja, genau. Das ist so. Dann habe ich irgendwann verstanden, okay, vielleicht muss ich dem Sender was zurückgeben von der vielen On-Air-Time, die er mir gibt, dass ich deren Ansetzungen einfach poste, dass ich... und so, ne? Und habe es dann, wie das halt so ist, auch so genutzt, dass ich damit leben kann, nämlich, dass ich zum Beispiel einfach ein paar Inhalte weitergebe, zu denen ich halt keine Zeit habe während der Übertragung und dir einfach kein Interessieren da, was dann wiederum andere Türen links und rechts geöffnet hatte. Aber das ist der wesentliche Punkt, dass du da natürlich irgendwo auf eine Weise, also das ist ja auch gut so, naiv reinmarschierst und dir denkst, okay, jetzt liefere ich mal die bestmögliche Arbeit ab, versuche mich so sehr wie ich kann mit dem, was ich tue, auseinanderzusetzen, mich entsprechend links und rechts aufschlauen zu lassen, ständig an dem arbeiten und dazu, das ist immer das allerwichtigste, also wir können jetzt über Vorbereitung und blablabla reden, schön, interessiert mich nicht, kannst auch nichts machen, wenn du performst, performst du. Und dass das aber wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal die Hälfte ist, das hätte ich gern vorher gewusst.
Und was hättest du gern vorher gewusst?
Also das auch, aber ich hänge Sachen so nicht so hoch, ehrlich gesagt, sondern ich glaube, das ist alles, es ist ein Prozess am Ende, es ist auch wieder eine schöne Flussklappe. Auch das, glaube ich, sieht man im Buch, es war alles für irgendetwas gut und es ist alles für irgendetwas gut. Es gibt Punkte, da passiert das, weil es passieren musste. Mein erstes Studium hat genau da aufgehört, als ich das Geld hatte, mir das zweite zu finanzieren. Und das hat mich da hingeführt zum Beispiel. Deswegen bin ich da nicht so, ich hätte gerne gewusst das oder so. Das ist eigentlich nicht so mehr naturell, weil ich es immer versuche, irgendwie zu erleben einfach und dann daraus zu lernen. So ist es ja im Leben immer. Ich glaube, ich wäre sogar langweilig gewesen, hätte ich es von Anfang an gewusst, dann hätte ich wahrscheinlich da, das wäre es langweilig gewesen, wahrscheinlich sogar. Das gehört irgendwie dazu. Deswegen, ich bin da nicht so, dass ich da irgendwie denke, boah, hätte ich das mal eher... Grundsätzlich hat es jeder mal so einen Moment, wo er sich das denkt, aber im Großen und Ganzen war alles für etwas gut und du wirst besser in allem, was du machst. Und ich mag so... Es gibt ja ein paar, bei denen weißt du, die kalkulieren ein paar Dinge und immer wenn ich merke, dass Dinge kalkuliert sind, verlieren die total den Reiz für mich. Total den... Es ist bei Menschen so, es ist bei Sachen so. Wenn ich weiß, wenn der Zauber weg ist, ist der Zauber weg. Deswegen, das gehört irgendwie dazu, dass es so war, wie es war.
Also ich könnte noch sehr lange mit euch sprechen, aber ich stelle euch jetzt trotzdem die letzte Frage, denn ihr müsst ja auch irgendwann mal weiter. Glaubt ihr, dass wir drei irgendwann mal vom Fußball wegkommen? Denn der Fußball macht ja schon relativ viel eigentlich, um einen weg zu... Aber du hoffst, dass du wegkommst vom Fußball?
Niemals.
Ja doch, ich wünsche mir das schon irgendwann mal, dass ich... also anders. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass wenn ich mal mit dem Beruf am Ende bin, wann auch immer das sein mag und warum auch immer das sein mag, dass ich dann auch wirklich ganz abschließe und sage, dann möchte ich jetzt auch nicht mehr weiter gucken, das ist schon möglich. Und irgendein hoffentlich dann etwas intellektuelleres Ich von mir wünscht sich schon, dass ich dann immer nichts mehr mit Fußball im Hut habe. Ich mache ja Boxen, aber... Nee, hätte nichts dagegen.
Und du aber nicht.
Mir ist genau das Gegenteil. Ich habe mit meinem besten Kumpel, mit dem Uli gestern in Berlin war, wir haben einen Traum und den werden wir uns auch erfüllen. Wir hoffen, dass wir mit 70, 65 einfach nur Kiebitze sein können. Einfach nur am Trainingsplatz stehen und sagen können, der Niner hört Juri der Pfauld. Das ist mein großes Ziel. Ich glaube, ich werde dem immer irgendwie... Ich sehe es ja auch an meinem Verhalten, wenn ich... Viele sagen immer, du bist immer bei Instagram und so, oder du machst immer dies oder du schaust immer hier. Wie oft ich Screenshots mache von, das kann ich gebrauchen fürs nächste Spiel. Und ich bin immer in dieser Welt irgendwie. Beim Uli ja genauso. Das habe ich gelesen, cool, das brauche ich. Das screenshotte ich gleich. Und selbst wenn... Ich habe letztes Mal auch zu jemandem gesagt, was machst du denn so? Ich habe hier mit Fußball gerade nichts zu tun haben, weil ich habe jetzt echt das ganze Wochenende gearbeitet, ich bin froh, dass ich nicht mehr runterkomme. Was machst du gerade? Ja, ich spiele FIFA. Dann lachen die alle so und sagen, bist du eigentlich bescheuert? Das ist doch auch wieder Fußball. Da sage ich, ja stimmt, eigentlich schon. Du hast recht, aber nicht mein Fußball. Also im Sinne von, ich will jetzt nicht irgendwie Statistiken wälzen und nochmal nachlesen, was macht der Rechtsverteidiger von Liverpool oder so. Sondern ich will einfach für mich doof dahin daddeln. Das ist dann mein Fußball. Aber ich glaube, dass ich davon nicht wegkommen werde. Also klar kann immer sein, wenn jetzt irgendwie alle Sender sagen, du bist bescheuert und hau ab, du bist der dümmste aller Zeiten und wir wollen mit dir nichts mit zu tun haben, dass du dann so einen Kulturfrust hast. Das kann vielleicht sein. Aber ansonsten hoffe ich, wenn es so weitergeht und ich das weitermachen darf, dass ich irgendwann das Kiebitzende und Nachbarskinder beschimpf.
Das willst du hoffentlich nie machen. Dazu bist du zu kinderfreundlich. Jogi & Uli, so viel kann ich verharten.
Aber halt den Stürmer, der zum fünften Mal fault, einfach schien, bis er unter die Nase zu reiben. Das war jetzt einfach das fünfte Mal.
Wie ist es bei dir?
Also ich sehe dich da auch. Du kommst da mit.
Na, war das nicht in einem Reel von euch, wo ihr habt ja so einen Unboxing mit Fritz von Ton und Taxis gemacht? Und war das da nicht irgendwie eine der Schnitzszenen vorher, wo du ihn fragst, hast du das Spiel gesehen? Er hat gesagt, na, ich war in der Oper oder irgendwie so. Oder bin ich mir das eingelaufen?
Ja, er hat das Champions League-Finale, das ich kommentiert habe, nicht gesehen.
Ach ja, stimmt ja, genau, das steht da auf dem Film.
Weil er in der Oper war. Und als ich ihn als er das Buch gelesen hatte, getroffen, hat er gesagt, war das so? Und er konnte sich nicht mehr daran erinnern. Er hat gesagt, ja, dann wird das schon so gewesen sein. Und er konnte dann auch noch genau sagen, welche Oper es vermutlich gewesen ist. An dem Tag, weil er da zu dem Zeitpunkt in der Regel eingeladen wird dazu. Da will ich hin. Deswegen weg mit Fußball. Da will ich hin.
Also ehrlicherweise, also die Leute werden, glaube ich, erschüttert, wie oft ich, wenn ich nicht muss, also Bundesliga muss ich ja gucken, Männer und Frauen will ich auch gucken. Alles easy. Also will mich da nicht drüber beschweren. Aber wie oft ich letztlich nicht schaue, wenn trotzdem noch Fußball läuft, die Leute werden. Also wenn ich lese, Jürgen Klopp sagt, er kann an keinem Spiel vorbei zappen oder Thierry Uri erzählt irgendwas über die Eckball-Variante von Furtino Düsseldorf, dann denke ich mir, so möchte ich nicht werden.
Das ist mal wahrscheinlich Marke manchmal. Also ich weiß, das haben wir ja im Podcast schon nur noch mal erzählt. Deswegen, wir schreiben ja manchmal auch, hast du das Foul von Chelsea gegen Arsenal gesehen oder so, ja? Dann sag ich, du, entweder ich habe ein anderes Spiel gerade gehabt oder ich bin gerade vor dem Spiel nach Hause. Schaust du dann halt nach.
Das meiste ist ja bei dir noch viel schlimmer als bei uns. Du musst ja tatsächlich immer alle Neuen sehen, so wie du dir das aufgebürdet hast, so zu sagen, du bist selber schuld. Aber du musst alle Neuen sehen.
Ich wollte dich mal fragen, warum?
Das ist durch die Hörerinnen und Hörer gekommen. Weil ich am Anfang habe ich nicht alle Spiele gesehen, logischerweise. Wer macht das schon? Das ging auch damals technisch gesehen noch gar nicht so einfach. Aber dann ist mir einfach aufgefallen, ich habe dann immer zwei, manchmal sogar drei Zusammenfassungen von den Spielen gesehen, die ich nicht über 90 Minuten gesehen habe. Also Sky, ZDF und ARD habe ich gesehen. Und ich habe Artikel dazu gelesen. Und ich habe dann aber festgestellt, das reicht trotzdem nicht. Dann schreiben die Leute danach, warum hast du nicht über die zwei Situationen gesprochen, wo sie abseits gepfiffen haben und es war aber kein Abseits. Und dann habe ich gemeint, Mist, dann muss ich es ja gucken. Und so hat sich das entwickelt.
Mein bester Kumpel, der hört sich alles von dir an und der sagt jedes Mal, es ist unglaublich, wie verrückt der Mann sein muss, dass er sich den ganzen Bumms da reinzieht von A bis Z. Und natürlich kann ich mir vorstellen, dass wenn Sonntag Abend ist und es läuft halt dann Bundesliga nicht mehr, aber dafür Zweite Liga oder so oder Premier League oder La Liga, dass du es dir nicht anschaust, weil du dir denkst, dann gehe ich aus Essen oder lade einen Kumpel ein oder so. Ja, aber dann lese ich euer Buch.
Trotzdem ist es aber das Erstaunliche. Am Ende ist es ja doch immer so, dass du dann denkst, na ja, dann schaust du doch manchmal wieder rein. Also ich glaube, meine Brand ist dann oft zu sagen, ich habe es nicht gesehen, na ja, ich habe es doch mit einem halben Auge verfolgt. Deswegen wünsche ich mir so.
Damit ich Videos habe, habe ich es trotzdem immer. Weil die Clips sind ja mittlerweile da und ich schaue alles. Also immer wenn mein Zuschauer mir schreibt, hast du gesehen so und so, sage ich, ein paar zwei Tagen. Also ich sage ihm nicht, sage dann, ja cool, vielen Dank. Aber das ist ja mein Job. Ich habe so, ich folge den richtigen Leuten bei Instagram oder folge den richtigen Leuten bei Twitter.
Ja, aber das wäre ja genau das, was du loswerden würdest, wenn du es nicht mehr müsstest. Und dann würde ich mir...
Ich will es wissen.
Ja klar, aber das wäre ja, ist ja logisch. Wenn du aufhörst, ist es ja vorbei. Also glaube ich, dass man, also ich hoffe das auch, so intensiv, wie wir das jetzt hier seit, keine Ahnung, 10, 15 Jahren betreiben, dass ich zumindest dann die Muße hätte, nur noch das zu schauen, was ich wirklich möchte. Also sprich, ich will es nicht auf Augsburg eindreschen, aber wir sparen uns Augsburg gegen Hoffenheim, weil ganz ehrlich, es gibt...
Ich habe dazu eine persönliche Anechothel, Jogi, die wird dir nicht gefallen. Ich hatte das einmal in meinem Leben, seitdem es den Rasenfunk gibt, dass ich mal nicht Fußball gucken musste. Das war, als ich die WM in Katta boykottiert habe. Da habe ich zum allerersten Mal, seitdem es den Rasenfunk gibt, habe ich auch ein Urlaub nur für mich gemacht. War dann auch, das war auch quasi ein ich lese jetzt so viel ich will Urlaub, neun Bücher gelesen, Herr der Ringe in zwei Tagen. Das war mega geil. Bester Urlaub ever. Ganze Zeit krank gewesen, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. So ist es halt, wenn wir selbstständigen Urlaub machen. Da stimmt ja so und dann war ich aber in diesem Hotel und logischerweise liefen da die WM Spiele und ich bin da kein einziges mal auf dem Weg zu einem der tausend Essen, die es da gab, stehen geblieben und ich kann dir gar nicht sagen, wie gut sich das angeführt hat und dann habe ich irgendwann gelesen ach jetzt sind sie schon wieder ausgeschieden. Boah, Gott sei Dank muss ich mich damit nicht beschäftigen. Da wird jetzt wieder was los sein.
Das ist aber, weil du dich ja, du hast dich ja aktiv aus Haltungsgründen dagegen entschieden und dann ist es leicht, glaube ich. So wenn du jetzt quasi dich selbst zwingst, obwohl es dich ja noch so catcht.
Ich glaube, aber die Spiele an sich, weißt du, das WM-Finale, dass ich das von damals immer noch nicht gesehen habe, das ist natürlich eigentlich auch eine Lücke in meinem Kopf, die ich füllen müsste, weil das war eins der besten Finals, nach allem, was ich gelesen habe.
Und damit auch eins der schlechtesten, aber ja. Ja, stimmt schon.
Aber ich wollte es jetzt gar nicht über mich machen, ich wollte dir nur spiegeln, es kann auch sein, vielleicht siehst du es danach so, aber gut, wir werden es sehen.
Zwanghaft darf es nicht sein, das ist Gott sei Dank nicht. Momentan habe ich den Antrieb zu sagen, ich will das durchziehen bis zum Umfallen, weil ich wirklich damit...
Ja gut, das ist ja logisch....
und dann kibbeln werden, das ist mein großes Ziel. Und dann nehme ich dich mit, da sehe ich dich mit so einer Piste.
Ich sehe bis dahin keinerlei öffentliche Trendings mehr. Du hast einen völlig falschen Blick auf die Branche.
Nein, nein, nein, Kreis-Klasse.
Ach so, Kreis-Klasse.
Wirklich den Nachbarsjungen beschimpfen, dass er jetzt wieder veräult.
Dann machen wir es anders. Wir spielen dann Alte Herren. Denn das ist das, was mir nämlich richtig abgeht, wenn man immer am Wochenende arbeitet und unter der Woche aufwied zu tun hat.
Warum spielst du einen nicht mehr selber? Wann soll ich dann spielen?
Und da habe ich richtig Bock drauf.
Nur trainieren, für nicht spielen, das habe ich auch keinen Bock drauf.
Dann machen wir Alte Herren.
Das machen wir.
Dann will ich nämlich sehen, wo der Uli wirklich gelandet wäre, ohne seine vier Krozband-Risse.
Das sind dann sehr alte Herren.
Bei den alten Herren. Bei den jungen Herren.
Stimmt, genau. Bei denen habe ich lustige Hose aufgeschmiert.
Bei den jungen, alten Herren, aber sehr alte Herren, ja.
Also, jetzt waren, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Hoffentlich haben die TV im Himmel mit Kai Psotter geschrieben. Ich halte es nochmal in die Kamera für alle, die bei YouTube zuschauen. Bei edelsports erschienen Sports, wahrscheinlich. Kann man signierte Exemplare irgendwo bekommen?
Da sind wir jetzt gerade schon, da sind wir ja mit dir am verhandeln bzw. mit der Bücherei deines Vertrauens, bei denen es klappert. Wir sind da dran, dass wir mit denen sprechen. Ihr habt mit der schon gesprochen, die war daran interessiert, hat gemeint, wir können das machen und das muss man dann halt schauen, wie die das hinbekommen, dass die...
Also kurz um Jahr.
Also kurz um Jahr. Wir arbeiten dran, dass es klappt.
Ich packe den Link in die Show.
Die Leute, die, haben wir auch schon gesagt, die Leute, die jetzt schon welche haben und sie unterschrieben haben wollen, Lesereisen, wenn es die geben sollte. Wir treffen uns vielleicht irgendwann mal, gibt irgendwie Eintreffen, wie auch immer. Irgendwie kriegen wir es hin, dass wir uns sehen und im Zweifel soll er es mir schicken und ich unterschreib es ihm. Dann ist es halt so.
Also ich will euch nicht disillusionieren. Ihr müsst auf jeden Fall auf eine Lesereise gehen. Da werdet ihr nicht dran vorbeikommen.
Genau, da kommen wir wieder auf dich zu. Oder weißt du, ich schon.
Okay, ich mag es bezahlt.
Das habe ich neulich schon mal zu jemandem gesagt. Das ist immer das Problem, wenn du Fragen gut beantwortest, dann kommen die Leute immer wieder auf dich zurück. Deswegen, und daher kommen wir zu dir. Es gibt halt so fragmenthafte Ideen und wir müssen halt dann schauen, ob das sinnvoll ist, das alles am Stück durchzuziehen. Oder, mal da, mal da.
Ja, da können wir mal nochmal drüber reden. Da habe ich ein paar, zumindest eigene Erfahrungen gesammelt. Also vielen Dank, dass ihr da wart.
Wir danken für die Einladung wirklich.
Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, lieben Hörern und Hörern, denn ihr habt ja diese Sendung hier auch möglich gemacht. Ihr wisst alles im Rasenfunk, Paywall-Werbe und Sponsoren frei, wenn nicht irgendwelche Leute ihre Getränke mitbringen. Aber gut, so ist das eben. Ja, mal gucken. Es wird schon die entsprechenden YouTube Kommentare geben.
Ich glaube auch, ich habe nicht gut geschlafen deswegen.
Die DMs sind dir sicher.
Aber sicher. Also in diesem Sinne, vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Feedback zu der Folge sehr gerne unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de Und ansonsten wisst ihr ja, wo ihr diesen beiden Herren folgen könnt. Und dann freue ich mich, wenn euch die Sendung gefallen hat. Und wenn euch das alte Tribünengespräch erinnert, dann ist es auch nochmal in den Show Notes verlinkt. Es ist schon neun Jahre her, erst mal irgendwann aufgefallen wird, der Sendung 2017. Hört da auch gerne nochmal rein, lange ist es her. Macht's gut, bleibt oder werdet gesund. Bis bald, ciao! Das war der Rasenfunk. Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser. Rasenfunk unterstützen ihr KNAUSA.